is there any way we could get a recap of
where we are well me you could do it
chomp intelligence roll there no it's
fine I will recap for the chat and for
some players that might forget guys if
you want to know exactly what characters
we are all you have to do is just click
exclamation point
it's [ __ ] pill time wait you're
taking pills dude come on man
Craig's doing their potions bro we thank
you for army in general but I'm a
colonel thank you very much like I was
gonna say just quit 2.5 yep
why stumble on the word when I could for
sure my train is everyone all set yes
let's recap let's recap all right recap
on the wfe adventures in D&D last time
we left our adventurers you guys had
just fought the ogre zombie in some
strange castle you guys remember how he
got to the castle by chance I was being
impatient after fighting the vampire and
then melody tried to have me make him
out make out with him and then Shaun cut
off his pinky because I melody
wasn't like a stasis mold and then we
threw away the deck of card TV was
distorted all going back all right
last last session you guys were leaving
the you guys had left the Crypt after
fighting the gargoyles okay you guys had
reentered the Crypt and had found this
rather dark menacing mist covering your
way into the crypt guys had passed
through which then you had found a
portal but taking that portal into this
magical clearing which kind of seemed
normal until you started heading in any
direction they kept leading you back to
this central clearing right and after
further investigation you found that
that central clearing was an illusion
covering up this long-lost castle it
seems that's kind of sitting in the
middle of time in space you don't really
know what's going on after further
exploration you guys had encountered an
ogre zombie as well as a strange portal
after you had killed the ogre zombie you
guys had entered into the portal and had
was put into this treasure room and from
there that is where you've been loved
off so here's the problem I see guys
we're level what - it's hard to know
brute towns are level level three level
three towns I feel like we're in a level
seven area be say we head back to
grounds more suitable there's nowhere we
can head - were trapped in the portal
still remember we went from the portal
it's made that of my portal I'm back
into the cavern didn't we
whoa beware on okay yeah you're still in
the castle right portal but we came back
you could make you a pretty mint uh Dom
let you guys decide I'm not gonna say
anything it's all you
I remember when we were at the castle
everything Arabs black around us that we
couldn't head in either direction and
then we only had the statues in front of
us and that main doorway in this castle
I couldn't be mistaken so what do you
guys say we go try and find the front
don't worry let's get out of here let's
recuperate let's restock on provisions
let's delve I mean guys and a weapon
we're gonna give you some money too
don't we he still has his money no no
I'm from from the last run yeah
no all my money went away but we earned
money so I have my face level gold that
we all earned here just naked walking
around a bunch of money yeah you know
where I'm he's someone who some would
wonder how he's carrying that money I'm
not laboriously how are you melody how
are you carrying all this money of 600
cards when do you guys split when you
guys split the money
yeah moly how are you carrying your
share hello you give that to someone
else you someone else can carry that for
you tell these tell someone in your
party the sum of money you're giving
them which is all of it so they can
accurately record it into their okay I
cut my pinkie off for you brother
don't come to me for more favors I was
gonna come to you because you saved my
life so I trust you with my sound lower
than happen forever where does it end
alright so how much gold never I have 37
gold
oh you have the same as last time 350
silver and 600 and do I sound okay now
and I've won rewind potion that weighs
the parallel word I would I thought it
was here it is what's the have
collisions there's my way anything yes
everybody has money does weigh the
weight will the weight will apply so
does someone have Melody's money yep
okay delete all the money off your
account right off your sheet but then
again keep track of it because he's no
zero you're putting yourself at zero
with everything just so you know no I
know I'm just writing in my sounds fine
okay sounds good to me
that's that's fine okay that's put in
your anal cavity it was in my ball now
it's in Sean's bag
one at a time none of this jibber-jabber
and over each other all right let's make
this a clean conversation but my first
thing the first thing let's finish
checking out this room I feel like we
didn't carefully go through it
so let's check it out make sure we've
got who we need before we start to
venture back out all right can we do a
little camera yeah
how about Craig you give me an
investigation check for the pork
occasion check it's happening all right
I'm going to my what do I do that under
investigation right here we go all right
I mean your key card look around and
from the last session you pretty much
gather everything of value it doesn't
look like there's really anything like
worth to you hey okay did you Thank You
Dylan for giving us up to solace my
brother you guys yeah you guys went
through these chests last session did
you get a new weapon all right
I did get any weapon it's black and it's
smaller than my other two-handed axe but
it has special mystical abilities that
Alex said he would touch on next time I
go into battle hey you need to find
sorry Nietzsche use that Alps I picked
up the golden staff to Alex okay so so
here's my thing then and then if we've
gone through this room that we have to
go travel back out through the portal
correct and there are there's no that
way just be sure there's no other like
branches off of this room right
unless I think we have to investigate no
no from what you you you you look around
you look around and it doesn't look like
there's you know you're not an architect
you have no idea what secret rooms or
anything like that look like so as far
as you can tell your everything's all
good
okay so just get the heck out all right
let's be smart correctly patient all
right so I'm gonna go down the corridor
here about 30 feet stop at the corner
everybody with me one second which one
of my hello yeah I'm here my bad it's a
little laggy the website
okay I'm with you Craig Craig are you
here can you hear me
one second chat where I'm experiencing
technical difficulties one second guys
can you guys give each other
[Music]
but you can't hear everyone out
one second guys sorry about that
sorry about that guys something bug that
on my xbox I'm just restarting it real
quick my apologies
[Music]
[Music]
okay because that's what a would say
who's not a dick sorry about that sorry
about that sorry sorry okay so what do
you want to do you guys could discuss
with Pico who fell asleep for a second
though pica here's our options we can
pitch a tent and keep guard two hours
per person for eight hours to try and
heal up but not we can just drink our
health potions
how about wharfs 9hp
are we gonna roll on the way out oh do
you mean Kreger low health and mean
Kreger not weak like Shaun and melody so
well yeah but it makes it more sense
because if you guys jogging wrong so you
guys are the most important to heal pika
let's throw our spells on them throwing
pushes on them no let's let's just try
to get out of here for now
see ya and lastly we ended up in this
place I would like to highlight it
doesn't matter does not matter
I cast a heel on Pikachu right now I'm
using one spell because why right now so
it doesn't matter what you say right now
so we're listening to crack - let's
finish what make you from all right but
let's all know I don't want it I smash
them throw on the ground it's a drink
and health if there's no splash potions
okay you drink them oh sure and it had
and you get it
there's no splash potion a bath say my
craft I will stab you you will get
stabbed
yeah okay it's been about it's been a
while you guys are kind of sat here not
really doing anything
what do you guys think I think Pikachu
actually I want who's in front right now
Pikachu's in front P control I want you
to roll me a d20 Emily they wrote me
it's been about 15 minutes of you guys
sitting there confused about what to do
just just roll on it's about four
minutes you guys we're not we're never
so sixteen you use you kind of feel the
party maybe but pika mostly you can't
feel down the hallway like a cold breeze
like it so this has been when you're in
this place it's like a catacomb dungeon
feel the air is very still it is kind of
damp it is kind of you know it has like
that ill to it but all the sudden now
you're starting to feel a faint cold
breeze come down the hallway okay and we
have no spell slots nothing we're just
white it was that way yes that's how it
is and we're gonna fight our way through
okay so Craig what do you think we
should do do we just turn to our right
what's the move I'll take point I should
lead the way will lead the way
wait what path me from what you tell me
what to do that's how it works just keep
going let's go let's follow the let's
follow the stream bro
okay well I'm gonna move to this right
area right here and then wait for my
team to go slow and one slow and then I
would have bad mistake you you come up
to this staircase and in front of you is
like where the hallway continues is just
a complete wall of cobblestone okay so
it's a dead end
Oh
it would seem as a dead end yeah okay
then we turn back how about this guys I
don't know what to do you go through a
portal I don't did you drag yourself
through walls no I
okay so you did all right I did it I did
it I was literally just moving myself
here's what I'm saying like we went
through a portal get here right then we
have to try to go through a portal to
get out we gotta go to the left right do
you see this decision come on no no wait
hold on dude I'm talking about to your
left there's no stairs here no bro as
you could see we're in a hallway so
statues and [ __ ] so Craig Craig what
you're seeing is it's it's like a
glitched out piece of the map so to take
when you think when you see that piece
of stair that's just like a a cube
that's not being rendered properly it's
just invisible to you basically so don't
let's go back to what you said hold on I
want to clarify so you said there was a
plane where you are right now where you
are right now so there's staircases
leading up there's about five staircases
up up up up up and then you hit Astra
tall cobblestone wall right right but
you smash it with your hands hold on all
done you said there was a breeze
somewhere where we feeling that breeze
so if we're just going by what your
character is looking like where your
characters looking right now where's
looking down at the wall you know I mean
he'd be feeling it to his left okay if
you're looking at the cobblestone wall
that we come upon we feel a breeze to
our left
if you're going up the stairs I'm just
saying I'm just using your character
because he's looking down you know what
I mean it's cuz I'm just sitting so if
you're staring at the cobblestone wall
you feel a breeze hitting you in the
okay okay so I'm gonna go to the crack
so hold on no no no no no I'm not done
yet
so I want to investigate the wall and
can I put my hand and feel around the
wall to see if I feel where any hair is
coming from you for sure can Craig how
are you gonna investigate what are you
just gonna walk up and just kind of feel
around just kind of touch it all I'm
gonna feel around stare intently if
there's any air through any of the
cracks I'm trying to tell me when you go
to touch it now right now I'm walking
over your hands kind of mm dissolve into
the wall
oh okay so we can go through the wall
okay Arthur go through the wall okay
what you're gonna do how it's gonna work
is you're gonna walk to the staircase
and then you're gonna tell me when you
enter and then that's how it's and then
I'll control your movement okay so
before I do that can I get my dangerous
sense I think touch the wall yeah sure
go for it it was dangerous that's it the
health potions replaced oh no no you
know any sense of when things nearby
aren't as they should be giving you the
edge when you dodge away from danger you
have advantage on dexterity saving
throws against a fixed it you can see
such as traps and spells so for instance
a danger sense won't tell you it's like
oh it feels like a bear is watching me
like that's not kind of dangerous I give
you give you if a trap Springs on you or
something but if you see a trap coming
you have advantage on getting out of the
way just throw me in there it moved me
in there let's go okay so you you walk
through the wall yep I take point with
my new black Daniel Craig you go next
I'll go after you come on and what
happens to him happens to us well I want
to see him Arthur if Arthur can talk to
us through the wall he moved I'm gonna
Peter don't say anything but tell us
what happened how do you don't say
anything W I got it mystical world of
things you get that pika did you see it
do what I sent you all right what do you
guys want to you guys being our third
guys aren't getting the response tell me
that you're going are all three of you
going in at the same time all three of
you I thought I got all of you but I did
all of you here I don't know where she
is
head bottom left yes well they're omen
alright alright we're back in the room
that we gots into the room we yeah okay
so we're back in the portal room so you
guys want to head outside so we can set
up camp because we know our way outside
well that's the idea right to get out of
here is there any reason yeah Archer
lead the way our third we'll have an arc
we got to walk over this dead what
happened to hard sir what is what
happens you know the same once we're in
the same room as you I'm just saying you
couldn't speak I thought I gave you a
very firm or very well right guys you
want to tiptoe our way out of here and
maybe just save a bunch of time and say
we walk out the front door I don't even
know what you said you should tell me
where you guys go so I'm gonna go past
the whole gorgeous body I'm gonna be
right here at these two brushes and then
because we're in a new area I'm gonna do
an investigation check well but we're
not in the
we're going back the way we came right
is there any salmon no because if we go
back the way we play so we go there's no
way out
does that make sense cuz I love the
portal here so there's another area
within this dungeon that we're in that
we haven't explored and we need to find
a way out bottom right corner maybe oh
why don't we why can't we get out we
don't know that we haven't traveled back
to the beginning you know we got
teleported there there's nothing there
you don't remember we were in a best
place we've not portal and then we came
why are we okay okay
okay but I'm just saying no no what's up
there Barry we came in here we came
outside there's a wall we came in and
then we went down and then we got to the
portal room the portal room sent us to
where he showed us a treasure that's it
was so we got to go left or right just
got back that I think what crazy friend
are you what cranks trying to argue is
that maybe after killing that or doing
something the scenario is changed I
agree with general Craig but all right
I've never heard Craig be wrong before
say I say I if you want to go with picot
or say Napier you want to go just tell
me it'll tell me I don't care Eko was
awfully quick to abandon his position I
don't know if I want to follow that type
of leadership alright let's try to go
back the way we kind of came so I'm
saying we start I would say we'd go up
without sound correct boys the loved and
the map the Dungeon Master is voiced and
not sitting up and right I'll go I'm
going up I'm right behind you
Craig can take going up to that first
hallway well I have to because you're
always saying you're gonna take point
but then you ask everybody what to do
because the week is
all right here we go all the way of
going on out
well would you go ahead and stop Greg
we're going slowly but there's a lot of
light Miriam explored
maybe that's the door right there yeah
but I think what did we go down some
these hallways in their block at the end
is there a reason to believe they'd be
open now I don't think there is
yeah let's keep going yeah I like to
know Craig's idea I'm going to Street
Dogg yeah let's keep going we're gonna
plan if you guys want to lead then just
say I'll take point where you are right
now where you just paying I'm right here
yeah as you're passing that left hallway
you kind of hear like faint like it
feels like muffled screaming like if
someone had a rag in your mouth and you
were yelling that's what it sounded like
to the left okay so to my left
well actually read to my right right now
just talking like map specific because
last time I feel like I was confusing
people so I'm just saying like you're
looking at the map and on your left you
hear muffled screaming okay I'm like if
you're going off your characters
position and we can if we want to take
that right now start doing our character
position instead of where you're
possessive okay fine so on your right
Craig on your right yeah you hear me so
boys I think we should investigate the
screaming unless like Arthur he probably
wants to just get out of here but I
think we should go over here I'm seeing
what's going on with the screaming I
mean we're you know we're a team of
gamma team there it would be morally a
man I distinctly remember the zombie
over
and I feel that may not be the strongest
entity in this dungeon well we can
always okay hey hey I'm here I'm at this
wall door whatever was all right you're
at this large you're at this large
double door and it's actually you you
can't it's it's kind of hard to describe
it's just like just think of a large
could beat like cathedral doors like
kind of like the ones that were the
cobblestone ones that were in front of
the portal room if you can remember how
to describe those french windows windows
unfortunately no paint no nope a stained
glass but it is barred from the outside
okay so we can technically open it then
right there's like it's kind of like
like that big piece of lumber you put on
castle gates you know what I mean that
like you slide across this yes that's
that is blocking that is blocking from
the outside all right should we open it
or should we not open it I have a can
trip that is a magic hand we could hide
behind the corner and I'm going to use
my magic hand to open that door get a
peek in around if there's anything crazy
we just run away I need to see what the
magic hand spell floating hand appears a
special floating hand appears at a point
you choose within range the hand lasts
for a duration until you dismiss it as
an action the hand finishes but is there
more than 30 feet away from you you can
use your action to control the hand you
can use the hand to manipulate an object
open it unlock the door container store
retrieve an item from an open container
or core contents out of the vial you
move the hand up to 30 feet each time
you use it the hand can attack at
females we care more than 10 pounds okay
got you a nice cancer it bro yeah thirty
feet away from this month they you see
where you're controlling it so you gotta
go to coast
we're moving the hands - I know the look
you have to be able to see it and it can
be within 30 feet Craig towards the
exhale
what doesn't worry we're fully plug the
door you guys gonna be fine I'm sure
I'm sure that's great idea - girl
screams and no potions no magic that's a
great idea
all right so pikas kind of chillin so
Shawn go ahead and do your thing
magic hand up here you can't you can't
it's me Chad somebody did not stand
behind me who is that this is all
happening with pikas standing right
there he's not okay he's that stay there
bring it all right go for it Shawn what
are you gonna do with your magic and my
magic and smoothly floats through the
hallway quietly okay so that to see
what's inside
gotcha so that magic hand tries the lift
of the think the the lumber and that is
more than ten pounds heavy so your hand
does not lift okay so because my team is
scared I'm just going to there's a
really good idea Shawn yeah don't make
that don't make that seem like you
shouldn't do that
no it's too heavy no it is a it's the
lumbered lumber that's going across
before I open the door and I hear doors
closing can I remove an investing
investigation like a little are you -
did you well have you taken the the log
off the door have you unlock magic came
to open it once you can get the log off
it is still walked so no you cannot open
the door slowly and pker okay so I take
the log off and then Sean does magic han
how about that that work yes or no
yeah hi Sean did you get your magnet and
ready I am going to remove the the lock
the mage hands technically still going
on no it defeats the purpose of your
standing right that doesn't matter
here's what's happening Piku is standing
rain from the door he has unlocked it
he's taking the log off and now Craig as
Sean is using it back a little bit push
the door open
alakazoo buddy Sean your hand slides it
opens slowly a little bit that's so sick
screams get louder you don't hear
anything anymore okay and now I can peek
through with my investigation
[Music]
yeah so you peek through you can see
that slit that's what your peek does the
rest of the room is very dark you guys
on the floor doesn't I think Pico so
when you go to your lame le stop moving
what I'm doing well
well you so just like in this situation
like if pikas doing something we're just
gonna pretend like it's turn-based it
wait for me to tell me tell him what
he's doing and then you can do your
thing okay
so pika you're you're investigating and
you're like okay there's two guys one
once wearing a robe and the other ones
naked no but I said the thought the Thor
know yeah but you roll the three so you
were looking the wrong way the hole and
you know what that's okay mm-hmm and now
I let my team take it back see how about
I'll let you move closer to this lid in
the door or I'll let you open the door
ah I feel uncomfortable with danger
sense and I pull back okay pick up hands
up no I'm trying to understand cuz
there's so much going on I rolled a poor
investigation and I was checking on
Billy is dong I know but you're gonna
take point
yeah the guy in the role Frank so you
are Shawn all right so you're opening
the door because okay move close to the
door and open it yeah unpredictability
in Shawn the door is open what there's a
lot of blood trying to do another roll
investigation bro what would be
investigation is standing for this room
okay
okay so great where are you in the room
yet Craig I'd say right pass no right
pass just say you're in front of the
door hallway you leave yourself there so
I can see
can you just say can you use move
yourself so I can just see where you are
right here okay yeah the door closes
right behind you
immediately I told you not to go ahead
of us very well listen to you Alex been
doing this doing it to us this whole
game so so
the door slams yeah okay
and he without just without you can't
reveal anything well I mean you can try
once you see it but I'm gonna show you
what's happening first and then you can
react okay okay this starts happening
because you better go in that door after
them I'll be right there
we can't let him I told him not to go
past the hallway door you should have
like at least two of us go in I know and
now we will write you know what role for
the door with the weights of Craig's
then all right where's initiative you're
gonna go to your concerts it's like next
your armor class I believe okay ready
I'm rolling roll yeah oh don't you get
little sucks for okay we will roll 9 all
right I win the initiative
all right it will be our turn and
there's zombie thing whatever wait I had
something for that I think there's
somebody else we're not there and don't
worry we're gonna need ice Peter sent me
this okay so these two Craig are gonna
be good within range
these guys will move up okay okay
they're gonna swing at you they're both
gonna attack you here nineteen and a
four so I think only the nineteen will
hit right before there's no way
yeah what's more that's on my armor
right or am I gonna take yes guys like
what six HP yeah I have a so that's the
okay now Craig your turn and then well
and then we'll have the the party take
their turn because they're they'll roll
in late into the initiative again okay
so should I should I try to flee or
should I just stay and fight that is
your call you make the decision not the
game ass when do I get my spells back
unless I rested right so I don't have so
you're out of spells I think you have
one you have one okay do you though well
I would just go with what you have right
now so if you have one if it says you
have one then it's me that didn't to
subtract it or you actually do just have
one so go for it go for it to last for
it oh yeah I use my melee attack a
weapon and divine smite because the
damage increases by one d8 there's a
targets undead yes okay so what am i
what is my what is Wyatt you're just
gonna attack with your short sword you
just type with the short sword right
short sword right all right here we go
good luck damn Bowl point three wolf has
three damage the word sword sword and
then you're gonna roll me 3d8 along with
that do you have an outro 3d8 okay
Booya nice crackers so 24 all right
which one are you hitting between these
two the one on the right so this one
how'd it go this one great is that is
that fair that's that guy's pretty close
did we ping him I just did but maybe you
missed me I didn't see it I didn't see
it
hey you said are you seeing that I'm not
seeing it but do you see my ping do you
see my green yeah all right now
now we're gonna roll into the rest of
the parties turn yeah you're down to
zero
all right there I did it okay I tried my
best
all right so you guys all you guys you
guys are in combat now okay hey by that
I just mean you guys have one action
things like that it's like you guys can
focus so can I move forward and open the
door from a group and melody and Sean
are the doors closed or and I
okay i'ma let me check 15 feet for me in
the door also sure whoever the folks on
the back with the purple rope he needs
to get closer which is Melanie no I'm
[Music]
yeah give me a strength check you guys
video is in your internal sheet in your
character sheet there on the length of
it where the three the six main things
you click the word strength
okay so you you you curl your when you
your fingers grip into the wood you feel
your fingers like indent and the veins
pop out by sparing the to that the veins
popping out of your forearms you have
that weird little vein in your forehead
that everyone thinks is gross but you
grip those doors and you tear the door
open and I wore okay okay roar give me
something oh my god three four five
zombies all right so that's my action
right Clay's national that's your action
for the child yeah your action is you
can still move you still have some
movement a little bit so it's easier for
melody and strong to I guess slide
through past me not really you're pretty
much already up you're already on the
wall basically right now so put yourself
back you're probably right there okay
alright melody and Sean you gotta help
up cuz it's getting [ __ ] right now I
guess I get my magic I'm gonna I'm gonna
put I'm gonna put my hands on the wall
and I'm gonna do it strength alone now
for what what
the doors [ __ ] opens melody what are
you talking about
alright well are you in there I can't
movie you I open the door for you guys
that's my action you not listening okay
well then I'm moving in now holy [ __ ]
that was a 15-foot draw for me so I have
15 more feet to travel but I'm gonna
stay here right next to that know Craig
aside now see all the dudes around him
and the general Craig is next to me I'm
going to cast poison spring
I know poison spell out and yes it is a
can trade oh yes so let me go ahead and
pop that B and I'm going to put it right
here on the map with my pee mark
melody can you read out for a second
what poison spray dude in the middle
before you do your thing
yeah put it no read it out loud get into
it come on I entered I extend my hand
forward a creature I can see within
range and project a puff of noxious gas
from my palm the creature must succeed a
constitution saving throw or take one
d12
poison damage I do that Oh your spell I
need to know your spell these he is it's
nine plus two so yeah I need that so the
zombie needs to be no damage gotcha okay
it will roll 18 so it says it says it
says extend your hand toward a creature
you can see within range and prefer it
so it's a creature it doesn't say it's
an AoE it just says that yeah it says
target area remember how multiple people
was that word in gonna get hit by it
when Pico was next to the boss but pica
happened to be 10 feet away so anyone
who's within 10 feet rings of him is
gonna get hit yeah but they're not all
10 feet
wouldn't you make it wave it winch which
one are you going for melody no it's a
range of tempted like no no it's saying
it's so Mellie what it says it's a range
of ten feet as in like you can that you
can it's ten feet away you can hit
someone but it's not it doesn't mean a
10 foot circumference that's a master I
don't remember when you use that what's
happening right now it did I can I'll
send you the clip oh my goodness but
it's alright there's a miscommunication
on it but when I'm reading it now it's
just like okay but I don't mean to I'm
not trying to screw you over but that's
how I'm reading it no it's fine yeah I
didn't work yes it's okay but it's gonna
turn I appreciate the effort right stay
out in the hallway Millie sometimes it
works out always the rule lawyer I can't
remember how to gauge distances oh
there's a there's a circle with a ruler
and you click and drag okay so I can
only get to the door well you can move
how many can you only move 25 feet if I
get thirty feet movement thirty like the
problem would be the problem would be
you be so your rehab melody and Craig in
the doorway so if you also went there
you might be squeezed it might be a
tight fit for you guys alright so I just
have no why don't you see where the
statue is which is right here why don't
you move it right there how do I think
that we're gonna [ __ ] I think
you just click and hold the pink click
and hold
I don't you go to right here late so the
next thing is after the zombie sits at
Craig we're gonna have a Creek and
melody pull back so we can fight them
one-on-one with in the hallway
hear me out do all that man but it's not
our claim no but that's what I'm saying
Craig that's the move first I agree with
that so just stay right there so I'm
like battle of thermopylae cuz if we all
go in that room we're gonna get multiple
sides that yep one by one by one by one
one by one so what do we got I mean
everyone's in the way they don't matter
I can't get it would be tough would be
tough it would be kind of awkward I
would give it to you a disadvantage but
you could still make an attempt if you
want to you've got a gig if I roll in 19
which isn't gonna have you never know
hey I'll give you my blessing tonight
step it doesn't hurt to try do you want
me to do a biga true my bird does not -
but if you want gap between the door and
general Craig the wall in general Craig
Shawn I'm gonna help you liking it Who
am I gonna he'll watch on just ok Shawn
he's got like a 5 health
it's wrong what you wanna do something
I'm not I'm not gonna be making yours
hey we can't Khanna me in our first
battle you skipped your turn in it
almost proved fatal I don't I don't
recommend skipping a turn if anything
scooting up forward would take some of
the damage off of the rest of us so it
would dispute disperse evenly amongst us
and then we'll retreat you and I have
the height of Health so you being a
human shield might actually benefit the
situation or you just dying it I'm
nailed so I don't like the idea on right
here yeah in the doorway don't skip your
turn use a major disadvantage module on
your character on your character sheet
I'm creating a fire bolt spell in your
attack and spell casting so instead of
quick if you're going to fire bolt yeah
go to your core your core sheet and
click on the fire bolt underneath your
dagger okay underneath dagger it says
bag of coins it doesn't save fireballs
or I should say dagger definable we
found it he found a 17 oh you moved up
Sean huh ok like this guy this guy okay
go ahead shoot your fireball at it
marbles your eated you're--oh you're
dead bro for damage
and 85 Welford you like the word
fireball I did close it 78 fireball to
do damn just want the word fireball
underneath in the chest so you do eight
damage and you hit this zombie right
here reason up seven four plus three the
corpse and you just and you just see it
starting to crisp three times is that
the zombie you want to attack because
like he's not that stupid that he would
come into a real he was focusing all
right there's a big there's a big X
through the zombie crisper dead zombie I
mean that's ridiculous
mister why not I mean come on Oh see all
I could see was a tiny little part of
the bottom axe it look like a health
Alex perhaps was I'm saying man here's
mine
we'll leave it hey hey hey I'm not
talking to you pika all I'm saying is
that we were hitting real world and we
have real characters and Shawn was able
to see into this room he was able to
have line of sight to that dude that's
already dead zombies are also known for
coming back to the dead so maybe that's
a good wait don't we owe you guys the
initiative order goes ah be sin to Craig
into you three poison spray reduction
will climb on top partner this zombie
will move forward just far from the
brink Chris body and takes damage this
obvi will hear sabe we'll move up
God look at all those long bees way if
you love listen I understand that melody
can trick you into your turn so here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna have two
zombies attack prey we're going this
zombie right here and this I'll be right
here don't you attack Craig this I'll be
down below can only hit melody okay all
right so we're gonna have the first two
on Craig here we got a 15 and a 14 Craig
with it which one of them hits I think
you got a roll you got a roll which are
almost on your armor class what's your
arm across yeah I think I'm at 10 right
if now we've been at probably like 17
I'm in summer class is that tackle it
yeah he's only a 10 on armor class yeah
am I supposed to be higher if you buy a
shield you can get increase they see and
there's certain paths that you can take
when you look as well Craig pulls out a
shoe before getting attacked by a zombie
well okay so we're gonna say you've had
your shield equipped for this fight
that's a bonus of +1 to your AC so I'll
change your own request to 10 11
okay okay thank you
if you get a bonus like nothing it
doesn't do any windshield
okay but so they both will hit you Craig
even with the Bonus theory see right
what about 6 and 2 so you take so I'm
dead
Craig is unconscious let's not say dead
yeah
he gets a B throws and then melody this
one's for you 19 that's
maybe so zombies are really really well
have such bad roles too they have such
bad roles they're so bad under the eye
and they're gonna hate you for three
melody you're hit fourth right okay just
okay so let me just real ette me just
maybe not reiterate but maybe let me
just let you guys know some information
when Craig is down he's unconscious he
will do death saves but if the monsters
are smart enough which I'll roll
intelligence rolls maybe depending on
the situation if Craig gets hit that's
two fails on the saving throws okay if
Craig gets hit while unconscious that's
minus two to a saving throws who fails
okay just so you guys have an
understanding of the situation here okay
I'm only saying that cuz Craig's up
front no it has to be a willing
conscious person so you can't willingly
take a potion if you're unconscious but
it is now that it's now the crews turn
it he usually would be Craig's turn but
he is now unconscious so Craig you're
gonna give me a saving throw actually so
on your sheet underneath temporary hit
points it will be the word death saved
success and failures all you have to do
is not rolling one and you're fine you
know it's right next to hit dice right
next to hit dice break to the right of
hit Isis death saves Chad we need some
energy can I get some okay that's it
right click the word death save click
the word that save oh yeah
give yourself one success on your
because it's three and three the bubbles
so you're one of the success alright it
is now the rest of the adventurers
meeting I'm gonna help you excuse me
it's my tractor stop
just messin yeah um okay I know we
should have beforehand but we got that
new axe you know Howard says like I have
great axe and Han axe how do I add that
new uncommon axe through that thing you
know I'm saying where I had like the
attack and damage type like figure that
out okay you're just gonna use your
you're just gonna have to use your great
axe for now later put in the stats for
your new axe oh I want to take a potion
and put it in read a book take and I
take a potion - I just cut it to do that
I've never done that you click it or
something
you have one potion we split it we all
got potions remember okay so you
probably push it up so what you're gonna
do is you're just gonna say you're gonna
take it your sensei you're gonna take
your delete it out of your backpack and
then you're going to roll then you're
gonna write to t4 and then your ads okay
so I do it I just like delete it right I
just delete the name it is backspace
looks and my thing and you said I'm
gonna roll away to d4 to d4 before to d4
I do that right it says for yep and now
yeah so you roll the three and a 1 I
have your 2d force and now plus 2 so you
get 6 HP okay one second chat so now I
have 15 HP good action or can I go in an
attack and your action would be I
believe let me go through the quick
reference real quick I'm pretty sure
taking a potion is a action of about you
show the provide scrapple shove escape
casts a spell use object yeah see you
you can move if you um
okay melody and Shawn are one of you
guys gonna move out yes you know do
stuff or I mean actually the doorways
block so I'm just gonna stay where I'm
at
and that's that alright because it's
ground my turn yeah
revised already want to lift him up
since I could do a little bit more
damage yeah actually you know what it's
not gonna hurt for both of us to try to
revive General Craig that's not gonna
hurt no it should only take one you guys
just cuz I think I don't think we're I
think you guys are going down the wrong
path here I'll handle this situation if
you medicine check him and you get a
successful medicine check you will just
make sure that he is successfully
rehabilitated he is not gonna be able to
fight check a massive chest just
stabilizes him it doesn't bring him back
to the fight okay
all right just yeah he does have to
think that throws anymore he can't move
he's unconscious but he's stabilized so
he doesn't have to make death throws
anymore okay cool yeah unless he gets
hit against for some reason all right
then let me go ahead and do the
lifestyle pray then I'm gonna do a
poison spray and I'm going to add it to
homeboy right and fitting homeboy right
in front of me
this [ __ ] mo let me let me tag
him all right hey uh your mouth let you
cast this and then Romi and intelligence
check with you real quick this is you're
already casted poison spray but roll me
an intelligence check yeah
okay yeah so as you spaz you're casting
the spell you just it you don't know why
you haven't thought of it earlier but
you think back to your studying and you
remember reading certain passages on
zombies and you remember that the
zombies have very high constitutions so
your thoughts on using a spell that
requires someone to make a con save on a
zombie sometimes this is the best idea
of you walk on 19 it does not take
damage all right I think I picked up a
golden staff yesterday or two weeks ago
when we were doing the the Luke but I
don't know how to add it to mine I
literally asked that question here for
Steve I know
well that's all yes so your your turns
over Melanie I'll add it to your sheet
wow they are wonderful thank you good
job nobody proud of you Shawn
get him up and then work all the way so
Craig has successfully done one saving
throw how many more before he wakes up
he needs to pass he needs to pass three
no no he doesn't wake up he's stabilized
so if he plays Gary wake you have the
halo so you can either don't HP HP or
what happens is when you stabilize
someone I roll a d4 and whatever that is
he's out for that many hours before he
wakes up that's not good this is kind of
pointless though he's up for one more
hour late probably like abandoning it
it's probably the best idea I'm just
gonna call all the zombies guys strong I
think you're telling me the truth hey
man I'm just here watch all right I
think you know more death throes is
probably the way to go so I'm gonna do
what a medicine trick a medicine check
would be what you want to do if you're
trying to say God I believe in you into
the death acontece go come on let's go
bro pray to the death Ont one baby
Wow Shawn's like I I'm sick of this wake
up son you you just
you hover your hand above his forehead
and you just kind of feel you're taking
that toxic energy out of them you know I
mean from the wounds that he had
suffered Craig is to be when you do it
at that I'm gonna do roll I'm gonna roll
to D force and you'll take the I'm gonna
roll you have no real 2d force and we'll
take the lower number gonna be out so
Craig is now just unconscious but no I
cannot use that saves pick them up
can you move Craig's body whatever
action actually move it
no no he's do whatever for awesome
spells all right I'm gonna move to the
corner of the room yep let me know where
you're going draw a line or something
yeah I forgot how to do all that
how about write that circle with the
line the circle with the I don't believe
you can move past that zombie so I'm not
gonna you can do that huh can't just
walk through things I think we should
fall back in front of us so let's start
falling back understand right here
I need it want us to go in this doorway
I will let you I will let you drag Craig
for half movement nice thanks thanks but
you can only say you can only go half
the distance with him but my well that's
about but I give a Semite thumbs up it's
about right I'll give it to you that's
how that's as far as you can go okay me
and peak about to get smacked in the
face who's lying um yeah so it is now
zombies turn crap don't livi zombies
converge on the zombie we'll move in
and I'm at can't [ __ ] there you go
alright so what we got here is three
zombies that are going to slam melody -
we'll be at advantage unfortunately
because they have have or adjacent to
each other
oh yeah wait how many yeah there is
three yep
yeah so actually here's the first ones
this gonna be on Pico cuz it's easier
peek of this first one's on you what do
you want do you 20 plus 3 god this is
are killing it alright
the attack is for seven then I do my
armor class which is 13 we get but he
rolled a 9 that he rolled a 21 so I can
almost guarantee you okay you're not
raging because what you're thinking
raging would make you take half by the
way I'm an HP melody melody here's the
first to it advantage okay 1620 leave
those both hit the third one will be at
non advantage and it's a crit that's
insane okay because the first one might
oh wait no it's a 65 a three eleven
twelve
he has no in the room no but I but you
use a natural armor class as a druid
unfortunately melody is unconscious now
these zombies have not missed these guys
are insane these are my best zombie I've
ever had I'm glad you're happy
oh yeah Lisa and Alex two separate
videos two weeks apart where my poison
spring it's multiple people but that's
fine okay well you're unconscious melody
it doesn't matter
oh yeah Shawn we got to clutch this out
for sure the constant angle and ran away
yeah well they don't have snow we might
have to flee soon so Prague is
unconscious though it is now pika and I
think it's my turn no it could be either
one I mean it's about all you got to do
right now hi I mean he just had a
fireball he can cast fireball fireball
that food let's go furball them soon see
fireball see good advantage because I'm
next it or not no the 17 will hit give
me damage
well zombie will take 24 fire damage
double boiler we forgot about that he
will cast undead 14 if they introduced a
zombie 2-0 hit points it must make a
constitution saving throw of the DC + 5
5 the damage taken so I need to I'd this
needs a role 29 con woo it's 24 + 5
guess what it's almost impossible so and
this zombie is burnt to a crisp
ok good job song do I have a poem that's
called a whirlwind and I just spit my
zombies dead like that oh yeah I do want
to drag Craig with me about 15 feet
then those
just drag them through the hallway and
consume I wish I had whirl way I just
spend my access all right your turn max
around make up make your bow I would say
attack and then drag melody all back
okay so it's this one's full HP right I
can't wait to see there is like a black
ball gets around dude right which one is
closest to me that this one no right one
can you because you're saying thanks oh
[ __ ] I'm mute it my bad I apologize for
uh but this zombie right over here is
that full HP or is it to half because
there's the darkness oh I can attack and
then I put this on I can attack and and
move
melody right
maybe it'll mean we some best thing
eating your to any grade x-range okay
I'm gonna use my new my great axe but
I'm using my black one okay that's
shorter does that make sense the new one
I got the great axe unknown that's black
and shiny oh yeah
is that cool 11:21 women's living will
head and give me damage big damage me
ooh
but still when actually no it's not a
mother aged no you're not raging so and
then
but +4 does that mean he rolled a 1 how
can we be so unlucky no first of all no
no no no no so ok Shawn what the +4
means is it means it's gonna be bros 1 d
20 and whatever that number is you add 4
to it right so that's no damage though
his damage is 1 d 12 plus 2 so it's even
more unlucky cuz he rolled a 3 all right
so I can I move back and pull away me no
his it no no it means that he rolled no
Johnny means he rolled a seven and got
four it's makin 11 to make it so he
could hit not for damage it was already
can I move back then
yeah so it's backwards you could go
backwards 15 right you can go 15 feet
back so like a drag yourself drag
yourself back run from mine and I pull
melody with me or melodies like halfway
how many do we only kill two wanna kill
- yeah two are dead smell look there's
boys but I believe I'm gonna rage and
each round is about a second so what I'm
saying I know but is there anything I
can do like what the zombies these
zombies will follow you know it's Mike
sir now if you do a saving throw right
what what are you talking about no oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you yeah cuz I
have to do it you got to do it for me as
I can't see that save on my Mac well
should I roll oh god no you're mine
you're mine same arrived you failed one
alright zombies drown okay this is the
ball they're gonna keep going through
this hallway you've gotta keep doing
your little candies come out the rest
seem like they're just standing at the
entrance of the doorway
I'm gonna rage next turn do them and go
and do a reckless attack okay shot you
need to do the okay alright well it's
here as his turn so miss our dream so
real
okay can't okay let's go nope
well the one on the right damage baby
11 so 20 no 112 so before he'll use his
undead fortitude we will roll and he
needs to roll at 20 to 22 baby want
babies 5 so he's dead he's dead
coming in clutch your boy all right now
it is
pikas turn and I'm still passed out so
I'm going to take a leak real quick all
right Shannon doesn't create up to do a
saving throw
can you do that one here what do you got
with my medicine all right give me a
medicine check hey let's go
and my turn but I move a little bit back
I have like everyone claps yeah let's go
yeah in front I got moral health no you
can go 15 feet drag to technical behind
yeah but I don't want or just at least
to the side okay cuz we want to be in
this quarter if we go to the hallway
then they're gonna get advantage and all
that other crap alright
zombies turn this zombie will move up
but if smart could hit their narrow down
into twos good job pika
you guys can barely see but those Ami's
at the doorway are not moving forward
they are oh stationary shiny how did the
fireball this is army yeah roses chick -
how's it going dragon monkey zombie what
would a [ __ ] zombie I mean RiRi I mean
attack the unstabilized
you know he'd attack the statue yeah
yeah that's what I'm thinking oh it's
past it's past the statue at that point
he'd attack is pen15 I'm doing now we're
trying to survive this zombie will okay
there's aa B will continue walking past
and we'll try the walk through YouTube
and we'll just kind of try to nudge by
you let's turn in none of you guys are
moving so it kind just thinks you guys
are all statues it kind of just is gonna
go look for Shawn do you want it it is
rack'em or do you want to do another
medicine check to stabilize melody no
it's John I know I'm asking Sean first
if it's right in between us I don't know
if I want to light it on fire
you want me attack and then you get
Milly do you yeah it doesn't it's not
shoestring give me my turn her hair so
I'll just go wrong it doesn't matter
it's the party's turn all right I'm
gonna attack it with my great axe I'm
not gonna rage if I get something good I
hit a 20 out of 23 and it's 7 nice seven
damage okay it takes seven it's not the
nice big job if you saw the dragon
monkey go back Craig what's up dragon
monkey how'd it go bro thanks for
everything
yeah D&D night all right guys
Sean's you're sure it looked like it
knocked him back a little bit with the
force moving a mask oh so you can see is
how far that's all moving it for all
right well at least say I'm gonna drag
this is a rough on one Delanie with me
rough deal movin right you wanna give me
a damage way to it's it's gonna roll
Condit needs a 27 impossible to get but
I'm gonna try anyways and it gets a zero
it dies zombie yep
I'm doing terrible I've already like
freakin you've been knocked unconscious
Melanie I need a death save yeah
Tony you have melody - it's no sense
constant reminder that if he rolls a one
he dies well if it's past walk into a
fight [ __ ] that's the pattern
Oh melody you know it is you gotta use
you gotta use um like Chrome you can't
use Safari no but I sign on on here but
I is one on one and the zombies turn the
remaining lives obviously you can barely
see at the edge of your screen remains
thanks Larry okay we're Sean it is our
turn another medicine check to hopefully
stabilize melody let's go baby I'm
tempted to give you my health potion so
you can get some more help up and we go
and then finish these fools no that's a
that's a it's a fail yeah it's a all
right I will do a medicine trick Indian
medicine oh well you guys both kind of
stand over a melody and we're like well
I mean we'd never really liked him
anyway so you had just kick them you're
like wake up seemed to be doing any it
doesn't really seem to be doing anything
okay so it's we're gonna stay in combat
here yeah you guys from the room you
start hearing that muffled screaming
again on the room
okay okay so that's their turn muffled
screaming muffled screaming zombies are
not moving but I'm letting you guys know
that you hear the screaming coming
really good it's our turn again more
zombies may have found their way into
the night yeah so we'll start with you -
that can do medicine check some you'd
like oceans Kenneth told you son cross
myself yeah oh yeah yeah you might be a
little I have a SS my tan Rhetor I have
one other potion do we know it just says
potion under it yeah that's cool right I
got a potion though I don't know I don't
know I don't know what that potion is I
mean yeah go ahead and drink it
stabilized more come on baby come on
baby for hours yeah because because he
rolled the natural 20 on his medicine
check right Sean what's the move yeah I
mean they team's good but it's not
natural 20 my entire character
throughout his entire progression tree
has no healing and he's a sorcerer what
are we gonna do I mean there's no way
out and I believe we have to go this way
to get out and remember we're all still
be dragging melody and and Craig around
so we just have to write comments to
give you I'm so confused
[Music]
left to kill we don't know there's only
four the rooms dark let's start you got
I'm keeping you guys in combat though
I'll let you guys know when you're out
of combat drag them out um so if you see
above you come Sean there's a room above
ours we could go there but I don't know
we could technically encounter more
stuff now we could go down and maybe go
back to the war the portal romance which
is technically safe I'm gonna turn Greg
thanks baby I'm gonna show you off I'm
gonna walk back up on top and now I can
see a zombie okay the one on the right
and you fireball fireball
Barbra Jean kills it oh what's the range
on fireball sixteen just sixteen feed he
hit an easily Janet Oh give me their big
damage baby six which one you hit the
top of the bottom and Sean specifies
it's a zombie that's alive know what the
next one yeah alright when you when you
hit that fireball Sean that muffled
scream inches closer comes a very
high-pitched wail very high-pitched oh
okay Sean just stay right there that's
your turn Craig gotcha okay so now it's
it's zombies turn okay cool
these two zombies will kind of be pushed
aside wait didn't he take dance yeah I
read your ear did I took his hammers
down guys don't worry okay you start
seeing something start shift towards you
I don't teach Shaun yet he'll be fine
oh it's no it's okay
I'm gonna rig it's a big shrub whenever
I'm gonna rage you're gonna fire bolt
I'm gonna tank I'm probably to get down
and then you get your fireball again and
then it's gonna die that's gonna roll
and then you're gonna save me I don't
think yes exactly well this is what's
gonna happen so it's your turn now right
you want my medicine potion to heal up
you have like what four lehp I'm not
gonna be surrounded by three unconscious
bodies you can give me a potion if you
want just remember you give me the
potion you your mother I take the potion
that's my turn wait okay the potions
shame on you Robbie intelligence check
you gotta make sure you have enough
thread investigate mmm let me find it
did one of the six things on the left is
your intelligence there you go
15 whoa you see that thing that you see
coming down the hallway or down the room
you have a knowledge of these wraiths
and you know that you have these rays
powers okay it's fine it's fine Sean so
it's gonna be Sean's turn shall I pray
to the nettle God and the rates are
gonna disperse a death God has been
doing me no favors I think we should run
away from the immense power means
they're gonna be hittin your piggy
buried like you have to I would like a
you know majority consensus on what
we're doing
there are conscious okay how about how
about this how about how about this how
about this you ready
I think you should roll it all right and
see what the God says and if it's not
good wait is it just one ray there is a
multiple Inklings
huge Oh are we gonna fight this thing
we're gonna fight it was it's getting
close I'm gonna find it it's not don't
know that this in a way a rape is like a
death creature I think that this would
be very much this is a million first
wait pikas down no I'm not I'm a week do
something okay Cass fireball you know
hit it
give me damage sorry okay I'm gonna move
the rate down so you can see it's how
far do you see yourself bar no no right
now should be able to see the health bar
no oh wait okay hold on a second
number three three I don't know why we
came in this room that's fine
screaming and Arthur said we did you see
it now I do I think actually had a
number though you're not supposed to see
a number like no number we do see a red
bar okay just a big it's just a big
thing because raping women grease your
nose yeah they keep calling me short or
some stupid [ __ ] it's cussing me out all
right the group the group has been okay
the fire bowl it hits but you realize
that this magical creature has fire
roads and will take half damage all
right run I don't know what we're doing
now and so it takes one damage damage
we're gonna try still move 15 feet you
can start all right working me up 15
feet top of the bottom which we O the
Doha road you can't go to it couldn't we
just go to the portal right and then go
camp there and they can't get to us
right hear me out hear me out are you
sure this are you sure this race can't
get through they don't know
I mean it's a good song going down yeah
I like the idea I'll go and do you want
to go we're going down
we've got to go off we know there's no
me no Craig and melody it's give you
guys about another minute to decide
until I right there I dragged Craig with
me I went from right here all right you
guys
yeah Craig Craig melody just drag
yourselves up to like 30 laps okay
just like drag yourselves with them hand
me the potion Sean Kerrigan and you guys
when you guys melody you guys are moving
yourselves up with them right okay
Sean and Craig it doesn't look like
Craig's doing that though looks like
Craig's just been left behind with the
game you're dragging your party with
Sean you so you hear that wailing and
then it kind of disappears the wailing
cop instantly stops but then like after
a couple seconds you start healing that
wailing again and the Wraith comes out
of the hole once find you and you
realize that the Wraith hasn't corporal
movement the Wraith can now move it can
move through units creatures and objects
as if they were difficult terrain though
they can move through walls
what's okay Sean this might be our final
fan biggest turn sorry that it went up
here I'm sorry it didn't know where you
guys were exact me in the hallway it
misjudged but it's above you Sean okay
toward toward toward the we have to
fight I guess all right are we gonna run
through the portal difficult hang on
anything about moving portals 13 or 15
or 30 feet you move 15 with care with
crawling with a difficult terrain which
is carrying a person man this is tough
Sean we're definitely gonna do we just
do we just trying to fight it right now
what's up I don't use your death yeah
can you pretty difficult right now death
dealers it a monk Oh magic goddess to
death hear me now I pray roll on me in
my time of need and take your minion
from my view we need not battle this
evil demon that be on our side you and I
have a connection death goddess we're
cool
take care of this demon and I will
sacrifice died another pinky for you
there it is all in your name death
goddess off by telling by finishing with
the death causes actual name I think
that would really help her out
the death got us his name a moral huh
glad a morte
[Music]
No zero my my rrh the name of the
goddesses your liking song God is crying
because I did she does she does I mean I
know you could take notes whatever you
want to help you remember on the fly you
remember that it was Magda the gaas of
death Craig just say Magda way worse it
is worse isn't it all right Joe you
through my dad Oh dearest Magna I call
that before I don't blush Magda it's
always been like this this is your your
minion in the dark are all right your
prayers fall on deaf ears Shawn you
don't know if it's not listening if it's
not listening or maybe you're
disconnected from her in this moral
place in which you are saying
you damaged my psychic connection yeah
cross street you're within range this is
a this is a can trip I've also turned
around and faced the demon before a
second yep okay you're just I didn't
make this into a spell yet but you just
got to row me a d20 so I'm totally I
wish I can trip on the gamer plan right
now tell you what how much time is wind
maybe had ten rounds so you do ten times
fifteen seconds and that's how long it's
been
yet it hits now Romi ad8 pick damage big
damage
no whammies no whammies three damaged
then the bar go dial you hit this you
hit deceased and as you hit it you
realize that it is resistant to cold
damage take one damage walk 15 feet 15
feet away with the other cord right here
Craig come on I can't move 15 feet sound
asleep no you got a draw I forgot like
right here hold on wasn't I moving any
there we go I took the long guy okay I'm
here right where you pick up your yeah
you guys are just keeping yourselves
Craig you're saying with Shawn melody
you're saying with Pikachu yeah the
caring listen carrying yeah my favorites
okay here's the band's we get back to
the portal and we take zombies TURN
RIGHT Wraith will push up and on his
turn will greet Wraith targets of
humanoids within ten feet that has been
dead for no longer than one minute and
died violently the target spear rides as
a Spectre so it targets the zombie right
here are you kidding me right now
and a Spectre arises from it so I'm
going to just keep the zombies body it's
gonna come back to life with HP alright
but that's its turn the zombie rolls to
the last of the order so it's gonna take
its turn next turn it just came into the
fight so it's not gonna go now it's been
about 15
it's been around died
round is 15 seconds on saying throw in
four rounds okay Shawn can I take a risk
and try it
I might be more yeah but five rounds
would be a minute there's been no
grounds for four hours melody then you
might be right
yeah no longer does that hitch Alec that
was a recent dead Tommy what I don't
know what you're saying
I hit the zombie surprisingly enough it
has an AC of eight and you roll this is
the reanimated zombie falls right back
to the ground it does not get to use its
undead powers a pika do your 15 foot
move next
okay
okay we're good
this is interesting indeed no Craig's
[ __ ] googling rates yeah well guess
what if you guys okay here we go
Pikachu my armors gonna swing it yeah
it's gonna swing at you baby they use a
life drink 24 target must succeed the
target must exceed a DC 14 position
Sammy throw or its hit points maximum is
reduced by the amount equal to the
damage to take in okay so what do I roll
roll what DC 14
they said it was wrong hello I
constantly the only thing I would allow
you to do be good is to help you survive
as much as possible
I'm not trying to be too harsh I'll let
you rage okay that's cool me primeiro
you show me your med ray you're at a
rages give me a DC 14 you need a con
saving throw come in saving throw and
you're on your life you need the roll
higher than a 14 can I say I'm like
reckless wait hon there's only one
option there's only one option let me
check let me just check and see if you
have it if you don't you're gonna be a
wreck
I don't actually that throws me on my
defense okay all right you actually do
hey you guys actually should all have it
maybe but PK you have inspiration
where's that and so it's it's above
proficiency bonus inspiration allows you
to roll the same thing twice so you get
a second chance of rolling : but once
you use it you see up there's like a
little dragon symbol pick it in your
inspiration do you see where that shows
that you once you use inspiration you
click it and it goes away and that means
you don't have inspiration but when you
have the dragon you can they can come
back a felon quote-unquote rest right
when I tell you when I tell you that you
get inspiration you guess so I click it
yes and now reroll your con in for the
life yeah
oh my god so much damage
oh yeah but you don't have to or take
its damage okay yeah hold on let me look
that up
Oh rest in peace headphone users so if
you don't if you pass the con you take
one eh no to DA plus three new product
what does that as a role that was 48
okay since you didn't pass and she
passed it's the last so two idiots is
gonna be like a seven plus three is
going to be a ten you got a hope for low
rules a nine um so you're taking care of
that you see take 404 you take the lower
in D&D you're always gonna take the
lower of the average down for HP right
so on we got we have no what Johnson
gonna keep fire building and doing one
damage yeah but Shawn did one day yeah
cuz he's yeah but I haven't attacked it
yet he's maybe my belly attacks will be
effective you know know that or or just
goes through its body and then we're
Shawn sheets a fire one up the ceiling
and light and light seeps through Shawn
aims at the ceiling and light seeps
through in there Wraith runs away there
you go almost it's your turn
alright what is this guy take out the
entire we can't run past this ah it's
yeah I mean it's a wraith so
I don't know how's it taking up the
hallway it seems like it is a spectral
being which means to this yeah very
spectrally something you can just walk
right through I don't know
so I want your Wraith I'm gonna do a
dashing slide and try and get behind it
oh I'm not a good it down behind this
thing I don't know it tried to stand and
face it and fire another two athletic
athletic athletic check we don't get
advantage you don't get it venom cuz you
are your spell damage do it unless you
use your weapon my light crossbow for
one Game six you're making it real well
casting another fireball yeah then okay
judge yourself with them alright didn't
move very cool all right if you would
come with me okay okay who thinks that
that if you guys survive this I'm gonna
have a popping melody okay so I can
attack and then run away still right or
no and I'm gonna be pro for all three of
those 19 out of 20 I hit that self image
and I was trying for six I move away
[Music]
all right it's slashing okay right okay
yeah no yeah I'm trying to figure out
how much damage the rate takes from your
six damage attack Rochelle what's not
lucky right now okay
this being will take three damage is it
6 out of 20 huh no no it's a six out of
a 1d 12 plus two um but isn't pica rage
so oh yeah that's upon year I'll add
another damage speaker this get plus one
damage on it okay actually it wouldn't
anyways but it doesn't matter cuz out
the user wait maybe that damage will
matter but we'll see and listen ray the
magic that goes through walls open and
we're just refer Oney pepperoni it works
no he didn't quit there wasn't anything
about portals in his description you go
through walls if you go through objects
and people but he can't I didn't say I
didn't say it it can't be true
what are we doing it's the bad guys turn
right now Craig well it's a zombies
right the Wraith will do this all right
your guys to turn get you playing what
happened to the zombie where'd it go not
what I was thinking I'm telling them to
outrun my book they're bullied and that
was unrelated to your gym is the flange
run at the port of a go to the port of a
little portal this move I don't know
what the [ __ ] it went but all right 15
feet Marcus 15 feet
and I dragged for you yes pulling a
mouse person so hard well I mean I've
been dead for seven hours Jesus yeah
well you know mistakes remain huh
I don't know why good the Wraith has
made their turn it's your turn another
15 feet
we're gonna keep mad dashing it to the
door you tell us where we stopped in the
process when the Wraith jump back in so
move us to the portal as you can towards
the door we did it the first time right
I didn't know we got to do it again oh
no do it again the next time we're up we
need to rescue I mean I like that we go
in half husbandly it makes it more
exciting I think this is the moment for
the moment guys finally so you guys can
just continue to run your nap now let's
get to the port I don't know that this
would be a great place to that things
still roaming around out there
wait I'm gonna I'm gonna turn down this
doorway
no no no don't see you're gonna there's
a door there okay where is it Bard
wait no here you hear it you hear an
eerie side view here in eerie silence
from height like and why I say you're a
just man just don't hear anything
we've camp in the portal room bro you
hear nothing so I know we've decided to
camp in a portal room but the Wraith
disappeared and could be waiting for us
well me it doesn't matter bro open the
door it doesn't matter cuz we're gonna
do so well against it
alright well I would rather climatic
Sean you're dragging yourself through
walls making me kind of mad stick to the
old I went around I saw you literally go
through I have dynamic lighting I know
where the light lines are so you go
right there
Sean let's camp in the hallway the camp
in the hallway then open a new door and
Sean I'm trying to sleep
you guys want to guys everyone on board
with the hallways well Craig your time
so you are with Sean no matter what
yourself with them it's not that hard no
okay okay okay
so certainly sleep Piku take some watch
first right what are you doing boys yeah
he could take a walk well good need to
sleep for at least four hours and you're
gonna take seven hours
it means seven first all right let's
sleep for seven hours okay so what's the
rotating shift because should I stay at
407 and watch you through that I get it
I'm gonna say before and then Sean's
gonna stay up for more
so then mean Sean bazooka far as I see
it sound good okay we're gonna take four
hour shifts until it takes
enough time to get 700 sleep okay that's
four eight twelve sixteen that's a lot
song right away yeah rotate yet the
rotate for four hour shifts twice that's
32 only four everything is so and so
it's gonna take a total of 32 hours of
everyone to rotate up stay at four hours
and they go to sleep forever
yeah so okay yeah that's fine so you're
just sleeping until everyone gets eight
hours ago
mm-hmm cool all right who's on first
watch hashtag dangerous inside the page
all right pika pika Romy d24 your first
watch okay so me and general Craig are
now conscious and awake one D 2014 baby
let's go pretty good okay for the
initial four hours nothing really
happens you you feel yours well I'll
tell you pika
here's what happens for the first couple
hours you hear you feel cold breeze
coming from this Drive yeah we're
opinion and then the next two hours you
feel that same cold breeze
I'm from above you all right me and
general Krieger up what's our HP it's
been four hours you guys are both at one
HP you guys are conscious at one HP okay
because why the Healey Posen I have a
healing potion that I would like to have
rested yeah they haven't really rested
they just they were they were okay Mel
you was out Mellie was unconscious for
four hours so he just says we have a vis
unconscious state Craig let's just say
two hours he's been resting for two
hours
so Craig Craig said 1 HP 1hp
but I have only good for healing all
right this is only after the okay good
for you
hey Shawn on your watch okay this is
what happens you start seeing this over
body get drags that that that's getting
pulled by an invisible force and that
gets forced into the ceiling literally
pulled up into the ceiling what starts
dripping from the ceiling and you just
starts you see like skin skin that's
been kind of torn off it hang from it
but that ogre has been pulled right
through all right so I've got four hours
of rest though that's good who's taking
the next four out well you don't you
don't have four hours of rest you'll be
sitting for four hours the first watch
oh yeah yeah you're right yeah and now I
have the milk
we're gonna do everyone can roll their
hit dice everyone has one hit die that
they can roll to hila
after doing that short rest rock and
roll a hit done
one hit died because you guys used all
your hit dies before coming in let's see
it's in your core in your core character
sheet
yeah Yeah right next to death saves this
hit die you just hit the word hit die I
just hit eight so I put on myself three
Arthur puts five slap 9 HP Sean puts
seven Sean is that your hit died seven
yeah
9 Plus 8 is 17 baby
you're saying mine is minus 4 3 plus 1
right add one yeah yeah yeah
see ya you cannot be above your 17 max
health so I don't know where would I
find like I don't think I do
well where would I have my potion it's
in your inventory inventory would you be
in your backpack if you had money posted
when we exited someone got last well
there were five that was art their art
they got you know either got zero I
didn't take one one or did you so we
drank a potion in the beginning of the
fight yeah
it wasn't me oh okay how's Arthur Arthur
Arthur picked up two and yeah he does
have one even though he didn't put it in
his inventory we distributed him one a
slippies exactly because I never use one
I never yeah you got a type type healing
potion in your inventory and then it'll
put one and then the weight is 0.5 and
then click on the healing I don't know I
don't know us getting a healing potion
that's boy thing no we're doing a lot
going you could not you and we all go
alright so healing potion healing potion
yeah Haley posted ok well then yeah
cuz I'm good I'm about to take watch
while you guys go to sleep ok let me
show that uh alright can I take guy take
my healing potion then sure yeah yeah
take it before you and then I'm gonna
take before it's 2 d 4 + 2 okay so
getting rid of it out of my inventory
right
yeah hit 2 D 2 teaspoons
hold on hold on I'm trying to get rid of
it
mix it all out it will stay like this
the slot will stay but as long as you
just get rid of it okay all right I'm
rolling to default plus 2 or you just
roll TT you can just roll to d4 and then
just add 2 to whatever they'll come is
mm-hmm
so you get a six [ __ ] yeah 17 you up to
12 you know a plus 4 would be 12 melody
how can I get how can I get more HP than
like what's in my um oh I guess I was up
to 18 right yeah you got good facebook
you guys go to sleep and you'll be at
you'll be a he's naked and telling us to
go to sleep wearing your pants I did I
just remember that yeah you just gotta
member the hit enter it's it's fine it
happens I did I thought 12 all right so
you guys are pretty much fully rested
you guys aren't gonna get a hit die
again for another group decides to sleep
for a whole day
I thought we rest together long rest all
right Walter steep for a long time so
you're gonna you're gonna see you so
what you're saying is you're gonna sleep
in here for a week oh I'm about it kitty
you guys because that's what a long rest
is we got to get out of here what's to
the left I don't know no let's continue
heading towards the door we got a head
towards the door yes up and to the right
and then up is the door but the door
I know exactly what's up the best emo
designer in this world we're letting
melody lead away somebody for cellulite
no no no we're fallin wheelchair emo guy
right now the way I love how azoic
deleted the goddamn way and I'm praying
to the [ __ ] oh just go I need my wolf
icon Alex make me a [ __ ] wolf and I'm
gonna growl at these [ __ ] until they
understand I'm the alpha in this pack
right now I'm we're going into the
[ __ ] door
all right we're going to the door I'd
literally just I can't talk anymore
shut up stop moving stop moving
don't go back
I'm laying melody it's becoming wolf
ever important that changes he's like
he's like one of those wolves that will
whine even if you're petting it it's
like I need Mort okay melody feeds away
my dude very well yes this guy's yes
okay we follow yeah I'd like to do a
wolf smell to see if I smell any danger
ahead dude a troll dead body just got
sucked up through this you can
understand language and then you know
better eyesight like elves or some [ __ ]
you know like hey I see in the dark
that's so much HP it I don't see my
excuse it doesn't matter
Oh porky not bad not bad at all okay
let's keep going keep going come on boys
stay on the wolf's tail walk gingerly so
laggy are you it doesn't show any of you
moving about now I see Sean there's
there's pika Craig doesn't look like
he's moving wait I'm coming dude come on
just being left behind lord knows if the
Wraith runs into you you'd be left
behind in price cranky with us come on
Frank spin the opposite direction
Craig go
well you're going too fast wait for
Craig right now I'm there all right I'm
the waiting room with the okay you're
here all right I'm going into this next
quarter okay boy wait it's drag me wait
you we're hanging a right dragon statue
where are we going
yeah I've never seen someone be so lost
than Craig when what's the Teen Wolf
theme songs in the crate that's that's
all right we are at the front door
Melanie's like teleported wait for us
waiting for us and Craig's lost time
thanks doing other things besides
watching it Craig Craig's like 20
minutes behind everybody Craig just like
music doesn't move anything for 10 days
for 10 hours
I can't I can't one of you has to open
this door I'm a wolf I don't go found
out the land doors open from when you
recently entered it all right all right
I'm gonna lose away right investigation
Shep melody yourself you know [ __ ]
yeah I'd like to do an investigation
check with my nose as a dog as a
[ __ ] wolf homie - you're
smelling I'm smelling around I got that
extra smell see yeah sure how about you
give me an investigation check
on your smell I'll see what you guys
know you kind of just end up smelling
your own butt and chasing your tail for
a couple minutes hell yeah
sounds like the wolf that I know yeah so
yep what do we see in front of us
there's a very see Matt pass stops you
wonder why the map stops John because
we're no longer in that hellish no
because if I were to show you what it
looked like it would just be the black
boy that you looked around when you
first entered the castle if you
remembered yeah call her she probably
will bring over Lambo I told you guys
there was no point going here because
there's no exit all right I'm gonna use
my special talent and skill of
teleportation and do your circle for
myself I am outside you know what in my
personal wisdom you could always draw a
card out of the deck did we throw it
away
Oh rid of the cards no no it's on tape
[Music]
I'd make an argument that maybe it's not
the best idea but you could do it for
memes and I'm doing a druid circle
outside cuz I need my abilities back and
I get half my ability because I looked
up druid circle these boys can't do it
with me
just do it that has the benefits all
right melody transform back to wolf
you're out of transformations okay and
then I'm going to use through in circle
I would need you to put this on the
thing so I know what the half you're
doing alright wait that was the end of
your transformation what a waste Oh you
should always try to think about making
transformations in battle melody you
might find more success you would circle
it's a passive ability so let me go just
read it out loud
alright I'll find it I'll probably find
it faster than you know a second level
you choose identified with the druid
circle such as the circle of land you Oh
God you lost this place you need help
with something I think none of these
thing disconnected actually melody we
can't intrude circles really powerful I
know he played might cry drop or
something give him a second so starting
at second level you could regain some of
your magical energy because I had to
find it by sitting in meditation
communicated with nature during a short
rest
I can expend spell slots to recall
[Music]
a bonus Yuri gave herself another can't
trip no second level no I did it I only
gave myself to just I started with two
can trips that second level which I get
a bonus cancer one additional cancer of
my choice okay sit on it right now
we were not like other everyone else
wild melody is inward thinking to
himself in his druid circle
feel free to figure out of a game plan
here I think we've come far episode
Shawn causing spot Shawn Magi I sure do
I can hit you with a fireball or rare
Frost wait a minute yep wait wait wait
dude I have divine sense dude I'm
supposed to know the location of any
undead within 60 feet yeah well you get
the cast it no it doesn't say that but
also it says that if they're in viewing
distant is they're not behind total
cover alright I'll give you a pasty you
[ __ ] option you have to turn around
and keep exploring oh I told you
[Music]
you can use this feature a number of
times equal to one plus your charisma
modifier and you finish the long rest
when your gain all expended uses yeah
okay so you don't have a charisma
modifier if anything can use it once you
use it once you use it once and plus
your Cammisa so you used him once when
you're in the crimp do you can't use it
again I never used an explorer there
might be another pathway to the left
right or one extra ability for this
battle peak there's no portal nothing
yeah I'm going for captures you don't
have to put that's all you have I have
fireball I have magic hand I have x-ray
for us and I have no
but like if I throw a quarter in there
and it disappears I don't have
communication with that quarter
we can't talk metric hands the same it
might be worth you exploring that more
don't let Shawn beat you down so quickly
on that Shawn I mean uh cards you have
yeah I mean you might as well use a card
it's always bad news but I think we
should try to explore magic hand more
okay I cast magic hand and I put through
the wall and feel around and see if
there's anything I can find you can't go
through walls I don't know what you're
trying to say leaving the black void are
you saying the black void in White
Ensign see your head can't go through
walls you're gonna send it through the
black void and feel around through the
black boy isn't that what we're doing I
mean that sounds like what I'm doing so
you're you spawn the black you spawn the
hand and you're pushing it into the
magic about five feet into the void the
hand disappears
okay can you call it back now can you be
like hey Anne Oh magic hey come on back
but hands gone doesn't I come back
alright so Sean you should go chase
after the hand and let us know how that
turns out okay get me out hear me out
let's pull this a little Marta melody
flip it out come on believe in the heart
of the cards Sean I will card out Sean
have the codes dice through the cards
all right I will take the car yeah hold
on here's the thing Sean Jesus a
creature that has zero hit points and
the creature becomes stable so if you
want to pull a card and you know it's
like a medicine stabilize you it's a
medicine check that works on the first
try stare the dying it's unlimited
it's my cancer I can read all you
[ __ ] and make you stable I am now
officially hold on melody what are you
saying your spell is nothing you only
have seven Canter's the true strum and I
don't see any of them that say no ad20
and the lowest person to rule the number
pulls the card just one 2d 2001
variable into nineteen who ruled the
sixteen are to my turn right I just
it's pika pika rules the Karthika would
have to so pig heed you dare you just
tell me that you're gonna draw a card
out of it there I grabbed it I grabbed
my hand I looked down at it hmm
and I drop the car oh wow do do you know
if you look at the stream any other
thing okay so what happens is this is
actually okay so what what happens is
you feel a little more charismatic and
you figure out the [ __ ] dope I care
about is that the lipstick no I don't
yeah you're you are your charisma is up
goes up two points and somehow you feel
you feel something in your back pocket
okay and you pull it out and it's a
scroll and you undo one while you read
it
you read it tempura tempura it's an
important town portal to know what it
tells you in this piece of paper it says
that you are now the new owner of a
small keep in the world of Acadia you've
got teleports you keep so your speed
so so what so what is he you drew the
throne card it is you gain proficiency
in persuasion and plus a small King
Pegasus he's right guys hold up hold up
so do I change my charisma to 20 yeah no
let's sleep for two weeks
let's sleep for a week IRA no no no no I
already gave you the increase oh I think
we should take it I think we should take
a rest you know give ourselves a little
nap yeah I dream that figure and regroup
so we sleep here and you work quickly we
need yeah we need ability
okay okay hear me out hear me out hear
me out we close the door no good close
the door we yeah then whoever's in the
purple robe they have the Moe's HP so
they're gonna take watch and then the
rest of us closely how about that so
roll York do your row we have to sleep
rosy roll we all have to sleep for a
week now we need a week we can't we
can't sleep for a week no do you what's
a long rest Alex it's not a week
obviously it's it's seven days what
that's what a long rest is yeah seven
days you know if you don't sleep for
seven you don't sleep for seven days you
just have to not be in conflict for
seven days you guys know so like the
scenario would be let's say for instance
you figured your way out of this and you
said like let's say you've finished the
session you're like okay we're just
gonna take a week in this town and then
we would come to session after a week
and we would start you up like that all
you could tell
I'll tell you right now that you can
just say hey we're gonna end and we're
gonna spend a week out front of this
Boyd castle and that's fine we'll see
what I've only got two rifles I'll start
off I'm not saying that I'm just saying
that seems ridiculous that you need to
spend seven days to rest that's come on
oh I know but the fact that I picked a
sorcerer
I don't mind turning around and going
all balls for the calls AHP well we have
no spell character no no no I don't want
to die we let's just go in there and try
[Music]
everyday you get a hit die back every
day eight hours voted for it yeah but
you're missing the point he's saying of
course just sleeping out here we're not
safe so I'd say with you know he'll dine
and try to fly it
yeah Alex basically said see what have I
got a new ability I've been combined
with my my poison spray to do it damage
plus my poison spray all right well
let's go back we all heal the little
yeah all right I'm not taking plum ready
laughing what is the right thing to do
here
now remember okay it's not always about
me laughing about you're doing the wrong
thing it's about me laughing about your
thought process okay hear me out hear me
out
we're gonna run okay we're gonna go down
did I jump into the void I'm gonna jump
into the void okay okay Craig you're
gonna turn around and jump into the void
okay wait we all do it let's do it I
guess I can't no no no here's the thing
I can't stand you guys talking so much
it's driving me crazy
so I think it's your time for me to take
the risk let's all just what I would
probably do it no no all right I'm gonna
go myself to start I think I need a
moment
as Craig jumps into the void Shawn cast
mage hand and grasps in and is taken
with him I like that pika that Lords
kind of artsy where you going with that
I like it I don't care I'm jumping I
can't I can't take it anymore so I'm
jumping in this and alex is typing a
long message you know we can't do
anything if you once you get in there so
if it's a health school soon
did you jump in Craig you're gone I did
I jumped in jumping so dude it hasn't
worked out well it has I don't care
what's definitely alright so that didn't
work so we have not to go back in Craig
your god I miss reading Craig opening
pathways to need scissors that's exactly
what it was
okay okay okay there way to take it back
okay all right okay I can't sing boy it
might be the best thing to do I'm just
messing with you Dulles the media was
throwing out random info I mean I'm not
saying I'm dead but Alex tied me is
just kidding about hey before we go in
we're all dead
guys let's pull another card guys let's
pull another card do you want be the one
that pulls the card hell yeah let's go
let's roll another Shawn you even though
technically you lost you don't have to
you could fight that give me a card well
you're holding the deck so no he can
take a card okay son you draw a card and
on it is like a shooting star flying
across an open sky
so you do get you can win son one wish
so Oh star I wish that you take us out
of here and Craig and back to the town
with the guards guy that's your wish
dude that's your wish do it of my party
I need to be very specific here very
specific with your wish why don't you
use the names of the characters missing
no no I'm saying Craig just be careful
Pikachu Shane melody we're in very good
health
completely well-rested in back into safe
confines
of the previous town in which we started
but we retain all of the material
possessions that don't have in our
possession you can wish for one thing so
what that would mean let me just give
you a definition of what I'm describing
as one wish you can wish for everyone to
be healthy or you can wish for all four
of you to be at a location where you can
do that do that the second one you said
you know I'm just saying when you were
describing stuff when you were
describing things Shawn you were like I
wants to be healthy and I wants to be
here and want everyone to be happy
that in my mind that's you're wishing
multiple things right to the location
and I think you should I think I think
you should save that way for a more
special occasion Shawn whatever general
quick say hey no ignore him ignore him -
the [ __ ] out of this place I'm just
going to Shawn you gotta make your wish
now before it goes away it's up to your
decision it's your decision he may or
may not be able to me and the other
three members of my party or at the exit
of infernal stinking dungeon castle to
the town the wish is that here's what
all four of them to be at the know he
said himself another three people are
you saying yeah okie dokie so you just
want to be put at the exit back to town
if that's an option but it sounded like
I was free tonight
Shawn you're so stupid watch something's
gonna be there so Craig where you are
right now you get get sucked up you get
sucked up into the ether all three of
you get picked up five feet in the air
and plops right at the edge of the void
okay we can I ask you a question Alex
remember what happened to me before I
got sucked yet you do I tried to take my
card okay that was the dumbest wish ever
this is why I jumped the first time all
right you guys paying attention yes yes
all right I just got back all right I
just got back at the village where we
started back in the forest where we
started that's not good that's not good
we need to be back in the [ __ ] it's
been here we have the opportunity to go
home
you jump through the void all right so
there's I never just remember I never
made a map for it so we're just I'm
bringing back to the main map okay
and so I'm you guys are conscious all
over here and I'll even get our
abilities back before we have to go
fight that race now you guys are here
you guys are here there's a circle no
the circle right here and then forests
around can we draw another card
you guys kind of remember what you guys
are talking about right you there's
nothing here yeah no a little added
flavor Sean do you guys kind of all come
out of that drop and you kind of look up
and you see a shooting star go across
the sky make another wish make another
wish and wishes the [ __ ] out of your
goal Sean did the thing make the Western
eyes upon a star wish that my team and I
could travel real far back to the town
from which this all began and never
return to this devil land okay that was
just that was just the car it was a good
ride now I give him a 10 out of 10 for
the ride but the subpoenas free wishes
are here yeah so you guys so you guys
are at what looks like you know you guys
recognize where you guys were just
previously you're at this opening you're
looking into that clearing and you guys
are on the edge of the forest right so
we're at the edge the forest so we're
not that far from
where we started that's kind of where we
know we are because remember we walk
south and it ended up putting us up
north we're in the matrix right now
we're the only out was the portal in the
middle yeah no two weeks ago and guess
what we went a [ __ ] summer and
there's nothing and then in the middle
it's just empty clearing because are
listening and we walk you guys got to
the forest yes because he walked through
the [ __ ] suck you off wall you
remember that okay
in the and and tiga went through and
there was a there was a portal and you
guys went through that portal and it put
you into this forest if you have okay so
here's the answer what's the best way to
find a portal we got a scene I'm gonna
roll the investigation for the group
[Music]
five ye dad you good old fire this is
five he with a lot
that's the first time playing 5u so I'm
giving them it's always hard core to the
rule school fire there's a lot of
there's things I'm not really
enforcement I notice a lot of
differences from 5/8 and off I be though
2e is better we were talking okay let's
move on
yeah so what happened here so Arthur
wrote something that doesn't do anything
Arthur roll when you roll like that when
you're old like that no it doesn't help
why not investigations this is the five
[Music]
perception or something
how about Craig you rolling an
intelligence check man so degrading hold
on how much of stupid you are
hey only so much all right so
intelligence check oh yeah you wrote the
same thing what - Craig being way mail
fortunately intelligence doesn't give
you too much knowledge about how to find
portals in this world unfortunately here
I go baby boy I'm not gonna give you a
notice you roll the four so I'm not
gonna be giving you guys you were basing
it off you can't be wrong all right Sean
John has more intelligence and the
middle big clearing that aboard all
peers and then me and the group run
towards the portal that Sean discovered
with his intelligence in the
hold on is there anything that looks out
of place or different can we sense
anything or see anything that looks like
I don't know if that's how that works
that's why I Alex and Sean has a very
basic average understanding of portals
he grew up as a sorcerer I would say
believe with your intelligence it
doesn't mean that you have an
understanding of how to create or know
where portals can be found for exits in
these worlds this is like an advanced
magic that you haven't fully studied
into yet it should be fair even in that
twenty might be tough for me to give you
information on this okay so here's the
same guys you need to have we need to
look around and try to see if there's
anything out of out of place I know but
we believe okay but we got to do it
again if we want to get out of here okay
you're right I believe Opik I'm melody
turn into a wolf smell [ __ ] do something
and remote exit forms oh oh and remember
this guy's last time we were here the
branches of the trees are broken off
there's a really big thing here that's
why I can't forget could be an ogre a
giant something big so there's danger
here don't forget I just think you were
I don't think you're remembering exactly
why all right boy let's do something go
it's time for me to draw a card No
hey melody it's your channel ticket card
come on roll the card do it right now
I'll roll 20 with you right now okay two
cards and you guys have only drawn one
card I'll roll 20 with you how about
that all right do it you're fucking-a be
descriptive when you drop a card the
deck by Shawn all right all right how
many cars are left how many cars are
left
I wanted not you started with you
started with 13 and you've drawn
oh we've gone to 4 or down a 9 yeah
we've got 4 should know you should know
cuz melody you drew three cards because
there you drew two in the crypt
then you roll one outside of the castle
that's when you're drawing another two
right so yeah five yeah you have eight
cards or remaining in this deck there
are eight cards out good even the heart
of the cards okay hold on a second let
me look this up real quick
okay why you guys have another
conversation about stupid bird in the
chat we're just having our own
conversation relax punish him Alex gonna
show you what's happening all right here
we go
Oh melody you pull out a card
and on it is almost it looks like a
crown jewel okay
and the card disappears into like golden
dust okay
replacing that is a wand Oh [ __ ] move
lavish jewels it has a base of gold and
you are you you recognize this wand
hello wand of wonder oh wow I'm
wondering what the wand of wonder does I
will tell you
[Music]
the lawn has seven charges while holding
it you can use an action to expand
expend one of its charges and choose a
target within 150 feet of you the target
can be a creature in an object or a
point in space roll a D 100 and consult
the following table to discover what
happens if the effect causes you to cast
a spell from the wand the spell save
there's no mega on gaming great um
thanks for the follow-up welcome where I
worst party member and we're this is the
first time yes praise Peter the winter
guy yeah no it's summertime right now
but uh this is our first time playing
different game nope it's your job all
right but that's what the card gave you
you're welcome
all right it's time it's time for
training pool a card I feel like what
was the one called again the wand of
wand of wonder all right okay dude I
want to pick up a what do they call
those rocks they have like two sticks
and yeah did I do that in pre no no no
luck god I even crazy I'm some paladin
dude pray to the Holies dowsing rod a
dowsing rod can I use a dowsing rod and
see if it does anything for me in this
forest doesn't give me any kind of
navigational skill why is that funny
I'm trying to
[Music]
when you're suing a dowsing rod has no
[ __ ] worth in this world
come on yeah that's Wow all right
Melanie Melanie Melanie Melanie melody
now is your Wang I'm Craig user one on
Craig and see what happens melody you
use your wand yeah roll the t100 yeah
roll with d100 do that do that do that
okay you roll a d100 not tell you what
it does
rolling rolling let's pray guys pray to
the windows go baby
wait this Craig okay with this Shh it
doesn't matter
Consultancy technically you can't [ __ ]
no I'm doing it for an area I'm doing
this to an area hey Ronnie I've come
back in okay the opposite you're just
doing in space I'm doing it in front of
us a point in space in front of us okay
I need you to tell me how far in yes I
will did you know you cast fireball each
creature in a 20-foot radius sphere
centered on that point must make a Dec
30 saving throw target takes 8 d6 fire
damage on a failed save so what does
that mean we all roll me everyone is a
role at dexterity saving through B 686
if you fail the dexterity melodies
melody past 86 you take half of it yeah
okay oh you need to beat at DC you need
to be to DC 11 or meet you at the meter
beat so you pass Greg okay
so Sean's gonna take the full dam sorry
Sean you said you take 20 well I was
kind of a Charles Charles 14 thank you
for the phone and welcome to worse parts
well I protein it's funny and I was
confused too that's why I wanted to test
it out yards ahead of me okay so I just
have 19 so we all take 10 help so I have
eight house what that's fine by me
so wait a minute we all take a hit I
thought it takes everyone takes 10
except Rashad who takes 20 it won't let
me modify my my health Alex
yeah you got to switch to the Pointer
melody I am on the pointer the map yeah
won't let us do it on the map
yeah oh no very good should let you you
should be able to just click on
yourselves it's everyone okay here we go
all right boys let's set up camp and
stay here for two weeks cuz we got to go
back and fight can I pull another card
with our abilities well yeah we get at
least try to figure out how to get out
of here I feel like we gotta try to
still get out of here there's no way can
we print it once you're gone Alex Alex
no yes yes yes what yes yes we see above
us yeah you can look up is there a Sun
in the sky no so it's just like last
time when you guys first got into this
area
it was perpetually nighttime there is a
moon in the sky but it is not moving the
moon is not moving not moving and where
is it located in the sky the sky so sit
straight up literally straight above us
like like it's like you know like
naturally when the moves the moon's
going over the night sky when it's at
like the peak that's where it is it's
not like it look like an unnatural moon
it's just like the moon's are stuck at
midnight or whatever you know it's okay
so what's some what if it's stuck at
midnight that might mean that it's
usually let's say for example
southeasterly or you know what I mean
yeah I know you're saying the man would
be a direct Direction melody can you
play the winter God so if the moon is
hold on harder I'm trying to move
southeast then it would be Northwest of
you okay let's say it's Northwest of us
guys let's try what it's probably going
to end up that we're back in the circle
but why don't we try falling the moon
and seeing if I like that idea
okay follow the moon all right so why
don't we start out and go slowly and see
and on our way if anybody wants to stop
or sees anything of interest maybe we
can do occasional effects to see if
there's anything of interest on our way
is that possible it's possible so why
don't we try that what do you guys think
I think that's a great idea let's go
okay oh game is bugged again all right
so I mean I'm not to move because I
don't know where to move on this map but
so we're gonna yeah okay just just speak
to me how you would how you're traveling
Sean Sean died no yeah he's he he took
20 let me manage in check Sean all right
yes empathy is amazing it was his idea
to shoot the wand at one of us and that
would be a tender above everybody all
right hold on where's the medicine it's
in there here okay let us say m oh hey
Sean get to pass you stabilized shot
stabilized melody it's your turn melody
how do i wake him I hold on so for four
hours
Sean is that far right and one of us
carry hold on but one of us carry him on
her back is that possible yeah the
strongest one pika
I mean he weighs about
I mean it doesn't matter you guys aren't
in combat so you're just gonna be going
slow because you're carrying such a
heavy guy you're gonna be probably
encumbered all right well we're going
slow but we're at least able to boot so
I say we go with that so wonderful I
roll a strength check just so I can be
like maybe I carry him with ease how
about that no dude that's ID how about
all right ah to meet each other ways
like nothing to me Shaun weighs like
nothing and we make our way around the
circuit pick Shaun up you have a very
firm grip on him but he is still
weighing as heavy as Sean weighs so he's
still gonna slow you down whatever all
right we're going in the circle let's go
what's the money where you going show it
Craig you had the okay you leave and I'm
going toward the [ __ ] moon man
ignore hasn't been less than right let's
look I'm doing an investigation check as
we walk towards the moon okay
well let's let's do let's walk toward
the moon for 20 minutes okay and let's
take a pause and see where we are well
walk in 20 minutes let's say that gets
us what how long would that train where
are we now and travel towards the
distance Alex 20 minutes yeah then you
got a mile in 20 minutes okay I think
the miles a good amount of space so
we're a mile in has anything changed
around us Alex does anything look
different than it did before or do we
need to roll investigation check Oh
perception all right Troy the kind of
perception Janet so that sounds good no
general has to roll it he's leading oh
yeah right
nobody's doing anything alex is trying
to explain something no but you are
leading hey what's up mark oh oh mile
the one we're gonna play to the winter
after this after a Belgian
like near like 18 to 20 minutes in you
know I mean when you're kind of getting
to the end of that distance you start
noticing that like you didn't really ask
since prior I guess but you it was a
clear it was a clear night you start
seeing big clouds starting to roll over
the moon
okay so there is a difference something
is changing so this this perfectly lit
up area is now becoming very dark
because the only source of light was the
moon the moon now wait a minute
so you could say we're on the Dark Side
of the Moon she doesn't have any more
transformations I think if anything
either arrests are just trying to make a
point that this would have been a good
part for the wolf to come out because he
has night vision or better vision right
and dark dark vision as a wolf okay do I
have anything that's good I sense evil
that's about it right we are at a
greater distance the flame feels bright
light in a 10-foot radius for an
additional point this is I got a third
camp for doing my groupid circle outside
the via net skew exits of that castle
that he wished us back to many times can
you use the druid circle once
let me see I can tell you don't get
unlimited can't trips off it if that's
right yeah I can only use it once I
think if I do have three spell slots I
can use it to rest for a but that's what
I thought I could use it to generate
spell slots but I have to use my spell
slots you jet to do a long rest or some
[ __ ] okay how it works put it
perpetuate night right you soon as
perpetually night we breast here and we
woke up with a stone right we've done
that before feeling tonight we've done
it before it's still night do that
before he went to the castle yeah okay
so well we did see clouds so the sky is
changing it is dark but I think so so
the moons covered up now so we can't see
the moon or do we see slowly getting
covered it is not fully covered yet and
we can stay walking towards the moon
that's what I'm thinking for now yeah or
we could pray to the winter time I see
you as a seal of the party pork pork I
mean doesn't yeah what we could pray to
the winter God
pray pray to the winter God pika
with hurry okay this is for Omega gaming
grid why would it matter about the
winter girl we're not even I don't know
it's just a suggestion
all right so I sit down crisscross
applesauce and then
and then I close my eyes and then and
then you know like you put your hand
together like a like a promotion and
then and this is a I don't know what the
winter guard is called but we're just
gonna call under God so now I'm gonna go
like this and then I'll be like Oh
winter god okay does that work
that was the worst forever wrong emo for
the for the winter guard wrong let it
work
I tried winter when I gave my hair for
that prayer we've had the wheel carrier
boat for that printer right there I've
had it anyway you would have the
beautyrx to some no we're walking a mile
we're going with demo Craigslist I'm
unconscious for a try Almudena let's go
so as you guys continue walking
another five minutes pass of travel and
the moon is now getting completely
covered by clouds now the the the
creeping darkness is now expanded
covering your whole vision you guys have
night vision
I'm 230 feet all right it's like there's
something new here now like there's a
new feeling like it went from being just
like a nighttime in the forest to being
like almost like a haunted woods that
makes sense you know what I mean so we
head back two miles and just
for two weeks and the feeling that I got
it is there anything the god of death
can do in Shawn woods yeah Shawn can you
do another prayer for them
that's God cause it did work in this I
would area for something sounds sleeping
for four hours all right well let's it's
been about 40 minutes we've got about an
hour so he has about three hours and 20
minutes left oh the winter guard is
Martha why don't you tell me the name do
well we got Magda as a god of whatever
all right Shawn okay we camp but make
America again I take watch Shawn
recovers and yeah Shawn big walk for
four hours yes I'm too weak are you guys
sit in darkness for four hours no no we
got to walk back let's walk back forty
minutes let's walk backwards forty
minutes to where we were away from this
haunted forest bro haunted forests
castles with raves and started over I'm
talking about do you guys have any kind
of dispersal spells no Craig Shawn why
not which is absolutely that is very
interesting Craig I have mending poison
spray and produce flame those that's all
I have right now
Mandy produce 20 dogs out on Mike hatred
so I got fireball ray of frost do we
like the trees on fire what's up
fireball ray of Frost meet miner
illusion
what's minor illusion on earth look at
it cat it's like I can throw my voice
last Federation though illusion also
ends up you dismiss it as an action
there that sounds fine to arrange for a
whisper to a scream or anything
Dave image of an object such as a chair
muddy footprints the image can create
sound light smell or any other sensory
effect it could image to the creature
using acting something I was a premature
infants illusion Louis okay but that's
just for me okay so what else do you
have
does anybody have any base skills like
that's not like a canned trip
are there any base skills that you're
given that you've started no no I got a
real winner of a character you guys
earlier Sean have the opportunity that
wishes out of your head in it
[Music]
you were told because you did only five
wishes but what one of those wishes was
that we be wish back to town Melanie you
said safely well Melanie and all the
objects no I don't have anything I have
I have nature I have this is that it's a
nature skill so sure there's a question
for you like him you have a chance yo
look okay where did you know I had
knowledge
I just if you just google it you can
find it if you're unable to find it you
could join our discord and Alex can DM
your the maps maybe hey wait I just
rolled it it's my senior on the water
other dude it's just so druids have a
starting so it's it's it's tough it's
like wisdom and intelligence which are
my proficiencies for being a druid but
there's no like base my kin trips are my
base abilities and so i have a saving
throw of a skill of nature so i just
rolled my nature but it was a low roll
so I don't think that's gonna give us
much skill I have religion nature I need
to hear it again sir I was typing out of
the questionnaire and answer what is it
because I as druid I have skills no but
I for my skills though I chose because I
get one isn't it don't we just answer
that first what's nature what is feature
yeah he just rolled it so what does that
mean dude
oh nature check is like so like if
you're a like a very base level nature
check would be like what are these
berries poisonous and [ __ ] like that
like base level nature checks also like
following tracks well that's more
survival oh it's like nature checks has
to do with will they are sure that our
third what do you what do you have I'm a
primary all I have is rage you guys are
not listening on our bird defense and
reckless attack that's it they did way
dangerous sense that's a good one
[ __ ] that's only for traps and crap it
doesn't do it ah
I know what my character does I just get
angry I know what it does it is do
anything wait guys as elves we have
trance elves don't need sleep instead we
met it too deeply remaining
semi-conscious for four hours a day
let's trance for a week bro alright
trance for four hours we gain the same
benefit that a human does from it so hey
with divine sense Alex it says within
the same radius you can also detect the
presence of any place or object that has
been consecrated or desperated as with
the hollows Paulo spell is that of any
use man I use that it's my ears it's
part of my divine smite I thought you
that does that put that in there yeah
look toward the bottom of that pair like
within the same radius you also detect
the presence of any place or object that
has been consecrated or desecrated as
with the hallow spell I don't know a
separate thing ok but it says as with
the hallow spell so it's saying well so
I can tell it does the same thing ok so
came you can't write the house fell be
the same as what your defines that's
what I'm saying
so should I cast that and see if it's
desecrated or consecrated you you
already use your things so you don't you
can't use divine sense again or I use
the one I use it I have five spells now
well because this was just a copy-paste
of characters that were already on this
map that I just used for this instance
because I knew we wouldn't be getting in
20 fights okay it's fair but I did have
one spell left after you woke me back up
you know I'm Sam I thought we discussed
into being in the fights you got to a
fight that you're like no I thought I
had one more spell and I was like okay
you did have one more spell no no you
use the spell that we and then we rested
in the round room and we need a week of
rest before we get a spells rest no I
remember me I remembered each oh we got
one hell I thought we also got one spell
back meditate for four hours we get
eight hours of rest
hold on it's like I just don't
understand why nobody seems to have
anything of use we just don't agree bro
level 3 crazy
what about insight what about insight
can we use an insight to do anything
oh you replied back to that Omega guy
when you ever chance Alex that's fine
well I'm just asked about wait I'll wait
for you guys to come up with an idea
because I'm coming up with insight
because I think the duck free thought
process as to where we need to go or how
we might get out of this mess I mean
obviously none of us have any good
spells that could just give us any did
anybody get weapon or anything that sees
through walls or hear me out hear me out
hear me out
well melody could use his wand again and
not shooting at Craig in US and he could
roll yeah we could potentially get out
of here
he's got the six more trolls there's
more charges I do how about that
also dude is crazy lately wait before we
do that though is Shawn a week yet cuz
he saw 0 HP no we need to meditate
because we're elves we can meditate for
four hours and you eight hours
all right let's do that let's do that
get Craig ready go get Shawn ready yeah
we're all yeah we're all elves everyone
of us are elves that's why I put it in
there all right so fine meditate Alex
from meditating all right do anything I
mean if we're wasting our time just tell
us it's a waste of time no no we're
waking up son
all right we better take Sean to wait
Sean recovers to try to a Hitler roll or
some [ __ ] on hold on but I want to
regain one extended charge Daly at dawn
I just want to okay night we're in
perpetual night so I don't know but
there's still 24 hours each of their old
one d100 there's no melody believes
right now row row row it's one that's
not on the second row kg boy big boy
wrote me one okay
not at us oh the last one hit 20 yards
away I will aim it 30 yards in front of
us no 40 40 dude come on okay 40 yards I
will take general Craig's advice because
I almost killed him did 40 yards 40
yards it's a footage you're artists
three feet right yes yeah your hurry
anything 120 okay yeah it's just a weird
way of saying things I guess all right
you cast a darkness 120 feet away from
you absolute darkness spreads to the
point you choose that fills the 15 foot
radius sphere for the duration of the
darkness spreads around corners the
creatures within dark vision creatures
with dark vision can't see through it a
non-magical delight can't illuminate it
you guys haven't seen one it's a trophy
120 feet in front of you is a 1550 box
of dark melody sure the wand again
you're all again Miller you roll again
no no wait you know what this might be a
good time to take a rest I mean
creatures in the dark can really see us
you don't want to head into that you
guys want to head into that and no one
is amidst a nobody yes there nobody
could see patrones oh my god that's not
what he said you said creature can't see
Melanie shoot good wand again wrong just
do it Jorma narayan yes just do it we'll
hopefully a roll lower always challenges
and we're gonna find out that like I
know well we could hear what it's doing
you know what I mean like how good would
have this been in battle I want to try
to get us out of here
Melanie roll again like whew like 30
years of this one we did we did roll of
darkness our I'm gonna do it one more
time that'll leave me with four charges
yeah yeah yeah let's go huh you know is
it 26 baby where do you shoot it where
do you shoot it
what do you shoot it I will shoot it 40
feet towards all right towards ya thank
you like 60 feet all right z28 thank you
for the party right the direction we
walked from not towards that haunted
forest Alex but to our right the
direction we came from Marquette is
there facing to our left is that haunted
force that we were walking two miles in
all right you cast stinking cloud 60
feet away from you create 20-foot radius
sphere of yellow nauseating gas centered
on a point within range
so Edgar farted brethren corners and
heavily obscured the cloud lingers in
the air for the duration which is and
Edgar farted Edgar came into the game in
farming using this again for three days
because I've seen yeah [ __ ]
yeah I'm it's like it's not worth doing
that
so and I farted and then there's
Martinez engage so I get I get my just
go with anyway all right should we just
rest in the darkness it's ridiculous
it's stupid
oh yeah I think we better just call it
and rest I think that's a good place to
save we can think about what we got to
do next time to get out of here how
about we all collect freight once you're
God together I mean my my issue is like
if I had played more D&D than I'm
guessing there might be a better thought
process as to what works like an obvious
choice that we're overlooking why don't
you pray to the death God again you can
cut my pinkie off take it take it cut my
pinkie Sambi troll no no no hear me out
hear me out you know where we were you
revived melody and then there was some
[ __ ] portal so how about this credit
the death God again because it happened
it works here do it charm it works it
worked they work and you need to do that
leave where you like you can't hear us
area in that era area area hey how about
this how about this you can try praying
if nothing good happens or nothing will
go to that import don't we just take a
break now won't we take a break and I'll
give some thought no brain of a god
everyone everyone in chaps a pray to the
god please it's gonna be a long shot
which is home
look chat said praise God
you have the Redeemers enough we're not
wishing us home I'm open to I you bro
you better do the best frame right now
do it every day madam showing us the way
homeward way to the portal you can stab
me or something - wait home come on bro
come on milli Nashawn holy magnet
goddess of death I call on you people
once again in my time of need
which seems to be quite frequent
recently but I pray that you take pity
on our souls we desperately need your
guidance to find the portal that leads
us out of this godforsaken land and off
to the village where we once began oh
goddess magnet hear my cries hear my
pleads of begging and take me right now
or in just land in this I pray to you
Magda goddess of death my soul is you
often say that say that say that sin it
friends soul he said melody soulless
yours is yours
he said melody he saw is yours that's
what he exchanged for this is I turn
into a death barbarian oh you're dead
like that like it like it all the
Warcraft
let's go baby
I'll carry you pika hey you shout out
Dylan as you're yelling as you're
yelling at Shawn make sure you use your
right name make sure
on the back of your neck you feel BC
talons kind of press into your skin for
pica right yes you okay
and argon all around you all around you
the color kind of fades away from
everything you know I mean like it was
dark anyway but like it's almost like
you've become colorblind and you become
paralyzed you cannot move okay
what's happening hello I think it's
controller died
Alex Alex got taken
I just said I pray for you pika okay so
that's died guys but I'm still okay
that's what I'm hearing that game
masters did it really back in town Alex
our controller died snapchat him
snapchat on Pico and tell them okay chat
snap example okay I'm I sent him a
picture Snapple cap Snapple in this era
I can't believe Shawn changed teams and
Judas Priest that's in that in that
rocket oh you kept telling me I had to
cut that's all no you could have still
wish to [ __ ] home dude for sure yeah
you're just asking for extra [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah it's been dead for a while now okay
so the talents
Kwan's to the back of your neck and you
become paralyzed and no just paralyzed
and you see this woman in black that
kind of form out of the darkness to the
light beside you you can't see you're
out of the of your peripheral
it's just like time kind of slows you
know like I tell you about how your
color kind of fades your site oh sure
sure sure
a little dark not my friend okay yeah so
it's like as she walks to you it's
almost like time around you just comes
to a stop okay and she comes up and she
almost walks she walks around you almost
like she's inspecting you as a specimen
and then she kind of runs her finger
across your cheek and as she does you
feel this burning sensation okay art
direction she kind of she looks at you
inspects you inspects you have looks you
over stairs directly into your eyes and
you look in the hers and it's almost
like an endless tunnel you know it looks
like you just see through her for miles
she looks as she says I could make use
of you and she turns and looks at Sean
who's kneeling on the ground and tied
knots approvingly very very happy with
her new disciple so far bringing already
another person into the fold willing or
not Matt doesn't really care so we get
teleported out he just said no she so
anyways
it just makes me that so yeah she
returns her gaze to you and she's like
do you have anything to say to me
okay Oh goddess of death magna I pledge
my soul whole heart you know I can't
speak to you goddess
I hope hardly uh pledged my soul to you
my wish is your wish is my command no
hope so my command she walks back behind
you it kind of has rest both of her have
normally long fingers on your shoulders
she's just like oh I will make great use
of you take us from your sake Judas well
as you're saying as you're thinking
those words he just that cold grip off
your neck is release and as that grip
comes off the color kind of comes back
into the world around you and time
starts to slowly resume back at a normal
pace but as soon as that happens because
so it's like as that colors coming back
huh the color doesn't stop coming back
as in this like brightness starts to
fill the world around you as the Sun
starts to crest over the mountainside
Dawson just kidding that's that's what
yeah that's what happened so pika woke
up from the best era and I'm away from
my homies I mean area area yes literally
all the same area no you guys are all
there still yeah so we're okay now
but fighting champion let's find a trend
all of us go back to the town let's find
a town yeah go back to the town we need
a week worth of rest and some Mead and I
need some ideas know where you guys we
don't know can someone do yeah cuz
you're the one who okay
hell yeah this this is what pika does
for the his friends I put my friends
before myself
all right perception it was a bad take
melody so take them before yeah but you
have a week so anyway so 22 Alex uh can
you let us know we are where we are okay
and if we back home thanks game after
okay hold on a second let me do some for
you
let me do some guys right off Wendy
that's it like McDonald's they don't be
on promoting all right so that's all
gone so you can tell from the mountain
range that you see the Sun cresting over
that you know that you guys have
appeared or pika you know you guys are
I'm gonna move you guys to the bomb
right
gonna make you guys smaller you guys are
smaller too well we're pretty far away
from where we were at you get you guys
have a brain back out of that realm
though yeah right here in the by the way
the sun's coming up over the or the Sun
rises in the east right sets in the west
yes yeah so you say right so you can't
see the Sun coming up here over the
hillside over the mountains PKU you kind
of recognize like I know exactly what
those mountains are okay okay okay hear
me out boys hear me out well if you zoom
in you can see that they're sure Brooke
is that a town or we can go to new for
nice is a small town which one's going
faithful so we could rest he just
recognizes the landmark the shadow
mountains are very noticeable landmark
for pica he has been that he's [ __ ]
he's traveled through so he knows what
they look or or or what's in closer we
can go to Crystal run is that a town
yeah they're Florida guys is just
zooming in you can see what's next was
melody I think that Brooke one the
Brooklands closer man sorry brother
yeah good alright alright so you guys
probably a day or two let's go let's hit
it
let's whoa right so that's probably
about like four hours that we'll know
it's like 20 minutes of miles kind of
what I do for walking pace okay dude so
you got to do 10 times 2 or 10 times a
money so 200 minutes let's go minutes
that's three hours and that's three
hours and 20 minutes
so it takes you about we'll just say it
takes you three and a half hours to get
there yeah okay okay guys end up in
Shire bro right now Shawn is almost a
full person in my eyes now stop
forgiving
sadhus I don't even remember that failed
with because he said because soul suck
off Shawn later I'm not gonna bring us
into the town right now fight you guys
see that like this small zoomin zoom-out
guys are at the man yeah yeah we see it
it's really small right so you guys are
coming in from the north you guys so the
way that the maps turned it is you guys
aren't coming in from the north can we
do another perception check or like
investigation maybe it's not a good town
guys you never know no hold on a second
no in the day map it's it's daytime but
just pretend like it's daytime I don't
have the date on here though yet so it's
daytime sorry okay okay which one's the
end by me really for this situation for
this situation
let's do any of these what do you ask
like which one is the in here like you
know like you have no idea which one the
end is you nervous this time you won't
have signs
okay can we scout the town go to the
town so you can guys can guy go to the
center of town like the town square is
they don't have a town square right here
but they have a pretty yeah they have a
little center area where they have the
well for well waters okay we investigate
to make sure that the town is not
hostile towards us as else is this a
friendly place sure what's up wait for
what you can tell it seems friendly yeah
these signs on any of the good danger
sense pika dangerous out there very
generic signs on some of the doors and
have the merit you have in yeah sure
once this in Craig Craig tickets and
let's go you drop that attitude Craig
how about that you find the end because
that's where some of the men are coming
out with some tankards of Mead okay
great let's let's go into the end boys
and see if they have a spare room for
rent
didn't you guys have a data for sale I'd
like to walk to the bartender and see if
there's clothes for sale
thank you walk in a few a few men as you
start trying to enter nude block to the
doorway early excuse me sir
melody I come from a battle where my
clothes were taken from me on an unlucky
role of a Clarence their shop so we can
get melody some clothes I have I have
gold if you show me the clothes show me
the money let me give you one goal so I
will - I give melody - gold
Thank You Shawn here's one gold yes for
a foursome clothes he takes this one
gold piece and he stares that like it's
the most money of ever he's ever seen in
his life
hey [ __ ] you can have my shirt and he
just tosses his to Europe this [ __ ] was
really big it looks like a dresser saw
it covers private parts the point you
guys are missing the point that like
obviously spending gold is
a big deal it's melon is money Melanie
could spend his money however he wants
let's get a [ __ ] about house every
game owners can tell we get along real
well
they're real excited we walk into how
much gold doesn't lady have left Sean
that's enough I have how much you
started well minus one I did not come
from Melody's bottom guys I did not come
from his but it came from Sean gold
coins that Sean or that Sean took for
melody was retrieved from Melody's bud
all right so we walk in now right I'm
clothed now and you go to who the
bartender and we asked are you gonna do
something like transition we're like
inside of probably as we just asked
already if there's any rooms available
for rent for you I and you can walk up
to the barkeep
who is currently cleaning out a glass
and what would you like you're gonna ask
for a room okay Craig you gotta talking
to a lady there's any vacant rooms for
us to rent out for me and my tree what's
really difficult since we're since we're
tired from the long journey yes yes but
for you'd have to purchase two separate
rooms I'm about a great guy charlie is
on me boys this is on me how much is it
fifteen copper night all right we need
seven nights so I will pay way Carter
let's hope oh my god
seven nights
I'm trying to get some money John
give me my copper son how many copper
hundred and eighty copper it's a hundred
and eighty copper I don't know a hundred
and eighty copper hundred uh country
copper I have to give it some silver and
say keep the change
Craig's were actually writing this own
thing but it's already oh yeah trying to
get robbed and washing all this money
well only the gold for whatever reason
that's what I just complained about that
you guys like it's not a problem
yeah no you're just flashing gold in a
farm town man that's very big money
around here
hey all right so I guess we're good
right we're gonna go to our rooms you
guys I am sleeping with Shawn because we
are fellow I've never seen Dean D before
ha ha well this is probably not the
typical D&D game but I'm glad you
enjoyed there's a briefly pad to tell
bro yeah hey can you say thanks know we
got two beds yeah thank you
thank you all right I think we're good I
think I think we're gonna rest here how
much experience that I 780 I do we get
an exception for killing those zombies
yes I am no we'll do that as we we
expand experience next week yeah we
should stand out I
I'm like yes that's fine if you want to
do experience now I can do that okay
enjoy chat and say you are enjoying it
and we'll continue to keep doing this if
not we'll end it yeah I mean obviously
after can yeah so just let just let us
know
ah me personally I have been enjoined do
you do this is love fun I love you too
sir
what if you guys you guys only killed
four five six armies I think oh you're
like oh thought you're five really what
else we got you guys 550 ones your 50x
be 200 you guys got 200 250 2270 that's
waves you're 70 you just go off Craig
its group XP 227 20 to 70 all right
dragon monkey says to the indie will
continue yes we will definitely we're
gonna definitely do it or finish in the
campaign mm-hmm-hmm although I don't
know it will be 80 when we finished but
it'll be great campaign finishes us I
mean that simply once-weekly yeah we're
ready
yeah alright alright what's up Craig
what's wrong
we're about eight to four hour minute
mark first tell you what's up what's up
I think oh my god no no yes I'll play
one game of uno